l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît et la
parole est à monsieur gérard le seul et
à lui seul merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à madame brigitte
bourguignon ministre chargé de
l'autonomie il y a deux jours les
électeurs de la 5e circonscription de la
seine-maritime m'ont largement fait
confiance pour les représenter et porter
leur voix ici par l'assemblée nationale
au cours de ma campagne madame la
ministre lors d'une visite dans une
belle association de service de soins à
domicile
j'ai constaté à quel point l'absence de
cohérence de l'action de l'état pouvait
aboutir à des situations de blocage
inadmissible et préjudiciable aux
salariés la crise sanitaire que nous
vivons rappelle le rôle primordial des
aides à domicile qui permettent de
maintenir le lien avec de nombreuses
personnes âgées isolées proximité avec
les patients soutien moral est pour les
actes essentiels de la vie quotidienne
cadence à respecter ce métier est à la
fois éprouvant tant sur le plan
psychique que physique
nous le savons cette profession est
précarisé avec des salaires bien souvent
en dessous du smic
résultat ce métier est en crise de
reconnaissance et d'attractivité
pourtant les partenaires sociaux se sont
accordés sur une revalorisation du point
d'indicé notamment lors de la conférence
salariale du 27 février
mais le gouvernement n'a toujours pas
signé l'avenant permettant cette
revalorisation salariale
les acteurs réunis la semaine dernière
sont déçus madame la ministre
alors quand allez vous signer les
avenants 43 44 à la convention
collective pour mettre enfin en oeuvre
les revalorisations salariales annoncé
une concertation pour le projet de loi
relatif au grand âge ne suffit pas le
temps presse
les travailleurs de l'aide à domicile ne
peuvent plus attendre
merci de votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député gérard le sol permettez moi de
vous féliciter pour votre élection et
vous souhaiter de bien travailler ici
dans cette magnifique enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale vous poser une
question sur la question des aides à
domicile merci pour votre question parce
qu'elle est importante
les aides à domicile ont tenu un rôle
absolument primordiale tout au long de
la crise qu vide l on serait primordiale
au quotidien mais c'est leur action
déterminante a été rendu parfaitement
visible au cours de la crise épidémique
et notamment pendant la période de
confinement elles n'ont jamais lâché
elles ont tenu et elles ont participé
grandement à lutter contre l'isolément
des personnes notamment les personnes
âgées isolées chez elles au domicile
vous avez raison monsieur le député
lorsque vous dites que beaucoup des
aides à domicile sont finalement des
travailleurs pauvres
des centaines de milliers de femmes pour
la plupart pour l'immense majorité
et c'est sans doute pas anodin et sans
doute pas un hasard si ce métier de
l'aide à domicile et si peu valorisé
socialement c'est historique
et à l'instar de ce que nous avons fait
à travers le ségur de la santé pour les
professions des deux soignantes
d'infirmières nous voulons dans la bras
le corps cet enjeu professionnel des
aides à domicile vous le savez le
président la république le 4 août
dernier avait annoncé qu'il mettait 80
millions d'euros sur la table pour que
les aides à domicile puissent percevoir
la prime qu'ovide dès lors que les
départements tiendraient leur rôle et
mettrait une contribution au moins
équivalente à ce jour un grand nombre
plusieurs dizaines de départements au
déjà réalisé sept crimes qu vide
d'autres sont encore en attente et je
les invite à travers ma réponse à
joindre leurs collègues qui l'ont fait
ensuite vous poser la question de leur
valorisation est donc notamment
l'augmentation du salaire nous allons
très prochainement débattre du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
il y sera question de l'autonomie des
ehpad et du domicile et vous
et que vous aurez là sans doute de quoi
avancer dans la bonne direction enfin
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué à
l'autonomie va démarrer les travaux du
laroque de l'autonomie j'invite
l'ensemble des parlementaires à y
participer comme ils l'ont fait pour le
maroc de la santé et là encore nous
pourrons enfin porter des belles
réformes pour transformer les métiers
les revenus et le statut des aides à
domicile que je remercie encore pour
leur action déterminante au quotidien
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vous demanderais je vous
demanderai de faire cesser ce brouhaha
et ceux qui veulent conduire des
conversations peuvent le faire en dehors
de l'hémicycle
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
la parole est à monsieur jean-noël
barrot nous l'écoutons
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
monsieur le ministre il ya plus de 150
ans la france a inventé le système des
concessions de service public notamment
dans le domaine du traitement et de
l'approvisionnement en eau
depuis les collectivités territoriales
ont bénéficié de la concurrence que se
sont livrés notamment veolia et suez
source d'émulation et d'innovation et
qui a permis à ces deux groupes de
devenir aujourd'hui des leaders mondiaux
de la gestion de l'eau et du traitement
des déchets au début de l'été angie a
annoncé sa volonté de céder sa
participation de 32 % dans le groupe
suez
le 30 août dernier veolia a affiché son
intention de racheter cette
participation
en réponse vous le savez de nombreuses
voix se sont élevées de nombreuses
inquiétudes se sont exprimées
d'abord sur les conséquences d'une telle
opération en terme d'emploi l'emploi qui
est au coeur des priorités du plan de
relance que vous nous avez présenté hier
on parle de 4700 poste menacé à terme
sur le territoire national ensuite sur
les conséquences en termes concurrentiel
et donc sur l'éventuelle augmentation
des prix pour les collectivités les
consommateurs dans une période où nous
voulons préserver leur pouvoir d'achat
quoi qu'il en coûte enfin sur le fait de
voir deux champions nationaux de leaders
mondiaux deux entreprises dont les
français sont fiers s'affronter au
moment où nous traversons l'une des
pires récessions de l'histoire du pays
mais le conseil d'administration d'
angie qui se réunit demain en présence
du représentant de l'état
veolia a fixé un ultimatum si nous
comprenons l'ambition de veolia de
construire un champion mondial de
l'environnement
s'agissant des services publics aussi
fondamentaux pour les français que l'eau
et les déchets nous ne saurions plié
devant aucun ultimatum ni aucun chantage
monsieur le ministre vous avez
clairement déclaré ce matin que l'état
ne céderait à aucune pression dans ce
dossier l'intérêt comme la
responsabilité de l'état actionnaire d
-g n'est-il pas de prendre tout le temps
nécessaire à l'examen de l'offre de
veolia bien sûr comme de tout autre
offre alternative qui pourrait émerger
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à monsieur bruno le maire
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jean noël barrot comme vous l'avez
indiqué l'entreprise
angie dans laquelle l'état une
participation de 22% souhaite céder sa
participation dans le groupe suez pour
se recentrer sur les activités
d'énergies renouvelables et de réseaux
c'est une bonne stratégie industrielle
et l'état actionnaire soutient cette
stratégie veolia a marqué son intérêt
pour le rachat de cette participation
on nous dit maintenant que tout devrait
être tranchée en 24 heures je veux
redire des choses avec beaucoup de
fermeté et beaucoup de clarté
l'état ne cédera à aucun d'ultimatum
l'état ne cédera à aucune pression
l'état ne cédera a aucune précipitation
l'enjeu est trop important il y a trente
mille emplois chez suez est une
inquiétude que nous comprenons sur
l'emploi il y a un enjeu industriel de
rester des leaders dans le domaine du
traitement des déchets et dans le
domaine de la gestion des eaux
il y à des enjeux qu ont manifesté
beaucoup de collectivités locales qui
est de garder des possibilités en termes
de gestion des eaux qui soient les plus
ouverte possible
ces conditions qui ont été fixées par le
premier ministre il y a quelques jours
doivent être remplies l'état souhaite
que cesse cette guerre entre deux
industriels français veolia et suez qui
n'a pas lieu d'être dans les
circonstances actuelles où nous
traversons une crise économique
difficile il y a une voie possible pour
bâtir une offre industrielle qui soit
satisfaisante pour les deux parties
pour veolia com pour suez comme pour
être j dans laquelle l'état est
actionnaire et je veux redire les choses
une fois encore avec beaucoup de clarté
l'état des nids pour veolia ni pour suez
il est pour l'intérêt général pour
l'emploi et pour la puissance
industrielle du pays merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
président damien abad
monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous m'expliquer pourquoi inciter
les français à se rassembler chez eux
après 22 heures
plutôt que de faire respecter les règles
de distanciation entre les barres des
tables des restaurants
pouvez vous m'expliquer pourquoi les
français n'ont pas le droit de se réunir
à plus de 30 dans les salles des fêtes
publiques mais peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent dans les salles de fêtes privées
pouvez vous m'expliquer pourquoi vous
inciter les français à télécharger
l'application stop qu'ovide sans le
faire vous même pouvez vous m'expliquer
pourquoi les français n'ont pas accès
aux salles de sport et en même temps
autorisé les piscines parisiennes à
rester ouverte
le coc vide serait-il inoffensive dans
l'eau monsieur le premier ministre les
français n'y comprennent plus rien tant
vos décisions sont contradictoires
incohérente et profondément injuste
à chaque jour sa nouvelle règle et à
chaque lendemain son exception votre en
même temps c'est la politique de la
confusion permanente
vous aviez promis une approche
territorialisées vous êtes enfermé dans
un en même temps anxiogène
technocratique et déconnectés de la
réalité des français après le fiasco des
masques en mars c'est la bérézina des
tests en septembre comment contenir la
vitesse de propagation du virus
quand il faut plus de trois jours pour
se faire tester et plus de trois jours
encore pour avoir les résultats
vous aviez promis un grenelle de la
santé mais rien n'a changé sur les ars
rien sur les lits de réanimation
rien sur les commandes de gand rien sur
le renforcement du lien hôpital public
hôpital privé rien sur les ehpad rien la
réalité c'est plutôt que de disserter
sur la france de demain concentrez-vous
sur la france aujourd'hui les français
attendent des actes quand allez vous
sortir de votre gestion de crise
chaotique et de l'amateurisme dans
lequel le gouvernement est tombé
actuellement
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le président damien abad le
monde l'europe et la france sont
confrontés
chacun ici le sait à une crise sanitaire
économique sociale d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle
d'une ampleur exceptionnelle qui appelle
selon moi
d'autres réactions et d'autres
comportements
cher monsieur le président avec le
respect que je vous pas d'une nature
profondément différent vous le savez
toutes et tous la situation sanitaire de
notre pays se dégrade significativement
comme elle l'est à l'espagne comme elle
le fait en belgique au luxembourg en
allemagne et partout les chiffres
j'y viens les chiffres vous les
connaissez
et ils sont inquiétants dans nombre de
régions et notamment les métropoles nous
regardons une batterie d'indicateurs
notamment le taux d'incidence dit
général le taux d'incidence est plus de
60 ans et les admissions à l'hôpital et
dans les services de réanimation tels
qu'ils sont et telles qu'ils peuvent
être projeté écoutez moi
écoutez moi dans les jours et semaines à
venir et c'est le croisement de ces
indices qui effectivement nous permet de
prendre des mesures adaptées et
difficile dans certains territoires
comme c'est le cas à marseille est le
gouvernement ne reste pas sans agir et
il le fait mesdames et messieurs les
députés sur la base d'une stratégie
cohérente à savoir
le président à savoir s'il vous plaît
chez les français contre le risque
épidémique tout en permettant à la vie
économique sociale scolaire du pays de
se poursuivre le plus normalement
possible car nous connaissons désormais
les conséquences d'un confinement
généralisée je vous rappelle à ce titre
qu au moment où je vous parle alors que
des débats légitimes se tiennent sur les
bars les restaurants les salles de sport
ou les piscines monsieur abattre les
commerces et les entreprises
fonctionnent normalement pour
l'essentiel même si nous encourageons
fortement le télétravail que notre
système éducatif accueille la quasi
totalité des élèves en toute sécurité
que départ entiers de notre vie
collective continue de se déployer
moyennant dans tous les cas des
protocoles sanitaires adaptés et
rigoureux cette stratégie repose ce
monsieur à battre plus que jamais sur
quatre piliers
trois d'entre eux concernent ensemble du
pays le respect des gestes barrières et
le port du masque le plus possible et
nous avons pris dès le début de l'été
des dispositions pour en assurer la
généralisation le triptyque tester
alerté protégés sur ce point
sur ce point nous avons fait le choix
monsieur aba'a de conduire une politique
de dépistage massive
la deuxième en europe désormais
avec plus d'un million 3 de tests
réalisés par semaine mais dans trop
d'endroits en conséquence de cette
politique le délai d'attenté pour se
faire prélever soit pour obtenir des
résultats a été trop long j'entends les
critiques sur le fait que nous n'aurions
pas dû supprimer la prescription
médicale et que nous devrions la
rétablir mais cette solution outre qu
elle recréerait détention et
rallongerait les délais chez les
médecins généralistes auraient pour
effet de ne pas entraîner dans les
mailles du filet les nombreux patients
asymptomatiques
nous avons donc privilégié mesdames et
messieurs les députés la prise de
rendez-vous prioritaire avec le
déploiement de barnum au cours des
dernières semaines et les améliorations
sont là selon nous avons décidé
d'acquérir nos avants décision plus rire
une nouvelle catégorie de tests dits
antigénique dans les résultats sont
connus beaucoup plus rapidement ce qui
va améliorer très significativement la
situation
le troisième pilier est majeur il
concerne toutes les actions complété par
des initiatives locales à destination
des personnels les plus vulnérables au
virus notamment les personnes âgées pour
autant pour autant nous avons constaté
comme vous que certains de nos
concitoyens ne respectent pas les gestes
barrière ne porte pas le masque le porte
mal
ne s'astreignent pas à l'isolément
lorsqu'ils ont été déclarés positifs et
la réalité
ces comportements sont particulièrement
constatés dans des espaces privatifs
dans le cercle familial ou dans des
lieux de convivialité
nous constatons également que la
contamination des personnes vulnérables
après avoir ralenti est reparti à la
hausse cela nous a conduits à xive et le
quatre piliers le quatrième pilier de
notre stratégie qui concerne des mesures
respectives susceptibles d'être prise au
regard de l'évolution de l'épidémie
sur ce point je réaffirme ici que depuis
le début nous nous appuyons sur le
couple maires préfets que je n'ai jamais
cessé de promouvoir depuis la fin du
décompte finement et nous allons
continuer car il est indispensable à la
fois pour prendre des mesures les plus
adaptées
mais ce dispositif mesdames et messieurs
les députés n'a jamais signifié un recul
et encore moins une des forces de l'état
puisque c'est bien le préfet
représentant de l'état qui décide en
dernier ressort c'est la raison pour
laquelle la semaine dernière nous avons
défilé de prendre des responsabilités
supplémentaires et elle est bien le rôle
de l'état
quand la situation sanitaire et
épidémiologique s'aggrave
certains décisions difficiles à prendre
et assumer sont du ressort de l'état et
l'état doit prendre ses responsabilités
pour autant il continuera de s'appuyer
sur les élus et les acteurs locaux
je recevrai de même sur le président
l'association des maires de france
et j'irai comme jeunesse essaie de le
faire en discussions avec les présidents
des principales agglomérations concertée
nous allons accompagner tout le
gouvernement est mobilisé les secteurs
les secteurs professionnels les plus
impactés par les mesures que nous
prenons et j'ai reçu ce matin même à
matignon
le secteur de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration et des bas pour trouver
avec eux les mesures adaptées à la
situation nous prenons nos
responsabilités et je demande à chacune
et chacun de faire de même
la situation du pays est grave nous en
appelons au rassemblement
laura ça nous en appelons à l'unité
mesdames et messieurs les députés
aucun dialogue est rompu aucun dialogue
est rompu
aujourd'hui monsieur le président à ceux
qui me reprochent de prendre des mesures
qu forte pourrait être demain ce qui me
reprocheront de ne pas en avoir fait
assez
je veux redonner espoir
ces mesures je l'espère avec vous
produiront leurs effets
produiront leurs effets et nous
vaincrons ensemble cette crise sanitaire
bien
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues la pertinence de vos
questions méritent que vous écoutiez au
moins les réponses la parole et havas
dames christelle du boss et soeurs merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre délégué aux comptes publics
la crise sanitaire que nous avons
traversée a provoqué la déflagration
économique et sociale majeure
la crise économique qui en découle d'une
ampleur inédite provoque une récession
estimée à moins 10 % du pib en 2020 avec
des conséquences sociales multiples pour
éviter que les effets de cette crise ne
s'installe durablement le projet de loi
de finances 2010 21 ans présenté ce
lundi intègre un plan de relance
exceptionnel de 100 milliards d'euros
toutes ces mesures auront pour effet de
produire un rebond du pouvoir d'achat de
1,5 pour cent dès 2021
l'ambition du gouvernement est bien la
protection des françaises des français
la relance de l'activité économique de
l'emploi tout en accélérant la
conservation la conversation et
écologique
je vous en prie mes collègues le
gouvernement mais aussi l'ensemble de
mes collègues députés de cette majorité
ont mobilisé massivement pour soutenir
les revenus des ménages dans la
continuité des mesures qui ont été pris
de court au cours de ses trois premières
années du quinquennat
enfin permettez moi monsieur le ministre
de saluer ici l'engagement exemplaire et
quotidien des très très nombreux
bénévoles et salariés des associations
de lutte contre la pauvreté et qui sont
soutenues par un plan exceptionnel
d'euros mesure qui doit leur permettre
de déployer des actions spécifiques au
plus près des personnes précaires pour
les aider à faire face à sept conseils
aux conséquences de la crise sanitaire
le plf 2021 et le plan de relance que le
gouvernement propose s'appuie ainsi sur
trois piliers que sont la transition
écologique le renforcement de la
compétitivité et la cohésion sociale et
territoriale
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez vous
nous dire quels sont les principales
mesures envisagées dans ce troisième
pilier afin de soutenir la demande et le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages
et pour que la crise ne laisse personne
sur le bord de la route je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier du shop ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée chars christelle du
boss vous avez eu raison de préciser de
rappeler que hier nous avons présenté au
conseil des ministres un projet de loi
de finances qui est le principal vecteur
du plan de relance
100 milliards d'euros mobilisés sur deux
ans un tiers pour la transition
écologique mais aussi un tiers pour la
cohésion sociale et territoriale
cohésion territoriale je n'y reviens pas
mais c'est important cohésion sociale
pour permettre de donner plus d'ampleur
encore à des dispositions que vous avez
déjà voté que cette majorité a mis en
place je pense à ce qui a été fait
autant 900 millions d'euros dont les
familles les plus modestes avec le plfr
numéro 2 je pense à ce qui est fait sous
la houlette de frédéric vidal pour mieux
accompagner les étudiants les plus
précaires avec l'abaissement du prix du
ticket de resto y
je pense aussi à la majoration
exceptionnelle de 100 euros de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
mais au-delà de cette aide aux plus
fragiles nous voulons accompagner celles
et ceux qui sont à leurs côtés
c'est le plan de soutien aux
associations vous l'avez cité mais c'est
aussi la volonté d'aller plus loin en
matière d'hébergement d'urgence
nous allons consacrer beaucoup de moyens
beaucoup d'efforts à aider les plus
fragiles mais nous avons une conviction
c'est que la meilleure façon de lutter
contre la pauvreté
c'est de garantir l'accès à l'emploi et
le maintien dans l'emploi l'accès par
l'enac salanque l'oise c'est la prime
d'embauché pour les plus jeunes
l'accès à l'emploi c'est aussi les deux
milliards celle que nous consacrons à
l'apprentissage
c'est faire en sorte que le retour à
l'emploi soit possible et elisabeth
borne d'avoir l'occasion de mettre en
oeuvre trois cent mille parcours
individualisé accompagné en matière de
formation et par l'insertion par
l'activité économique puisque nous
allons créer 35000 places en la matière
et puis enfin conserver son emploi c'est
conserver son revenu et la france peut
s'enorgueillir d'avoir mis en place le
régime de d'indemnisation du chômage
partiel le plus généreux de toute l'eau
cdo ocde a d'ailleurs dit que nous
sommes le pays qui a le mieux protéger
leurs revenus des salariés le revenu de
ses concitoyens avec une baisse de
pouvoir d'achat de seulement 0 5%
quand la croissance chute de 10% l'année
prochaine nous continuerons avec
l'activité partielle de longue durée
pour 7 milliards d'euros
elisa de born a pris en charge la
supervision depuis 300 accords qui ont
déjà été signés en la matière protéger
les français garantir le maintien de
laurent croizier garantir le revenu
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur le président andré chassaigne
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre la
présentation du projet de loi de
finances confirme que votre plan de
relance ne répondra pas à l'urgence
économique écologique et social sur le
montant d'abord le chiffre des 100
milliards d'euros est brandie tel un
slogan mais 35 milliards d'euros
seulement seront inclus dans le budget
pas de quoi sauter comme des cabris
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
sur le fond ensuite une crampe mental
vous paralyse votre fameuse politique de
l'offre qui n'est qu'une politique
obsessionnel de conservation des profits
produisant des mesures injustes et
inefficaces
sur les 35 milliards débloqués près d'un
tiers servira essentiellement à réduire
l'imposition des grandes entreprises une
nouvelle fois vous leur offrez un
blanc-seing sans ciblage sans contrainte
sans contrôle sans contrepartie
en espérant créer quelques emplois mais
les faits sont têtus très têtu
la multiplication des plans sociaux met
en lumière l'impasse de votre politique
pire votre plan de relance ferme les
yeux sur le désastre social qui laisse
depuis plusieurs mois sur le carreau des
millions de français étudiant
travailleur indépendant intérimaire tous
les précaires que vous abandonnez à leur
propre sort
à l'opposé de votre politique dans notre
temps votre politique dans notre temps
les députés communistes prônent un
bouleversement de cette logique
mortifère un soutien massif aux français
qui ont le plus souffert de la crise
parce que c'est juste socialement et
économiquement utile un soutien aux
entreprises qui doit être ciblée pour
être efficace en donnant la priorité aux
petites entreprises de nos territoires
et à celles qui sont écologiquement
vertueux et surtout surtout monsieur le
premier ministre
contrôle et que cette urgence cet argent
serve au maintien des emplois
monsieur le premier ministre a qu'un à
15 l'inversion de votre logique
économique pour enfin briller depuis
2000 testé je le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le président chassaigne
le plan de relance dont vous débattre et
dans le cadre de la loi de finances pour
2021 a précisément précisément monsieur
le président un objectif premier
un objectif majeur l'emploi l'emploi
pour tous
l'emploi pour les plus jeunes l'emploi
dans les territoires 7
mesdames et messieurs et nous pouvons en
être fiers
un des plans de relance les plus
ambitieux en europe 1 des plans de
relance les plus écologiques avec 30
milliards consacrés à cet objectif
je vous rappelle mais vous le savez cher
président que nous avons vous avez le
parlement a voté déjà pour près de 470
milliards d'euros pour faire face aux
premières conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
ensuite ensuite en particulier d'enlever
les mêmes droits 10 milliards d'euros en
avance de phase du président du plan de
relance ont été votées par la
représentation nationale en particulier
puisque vous y avez fait allusion le
plan d'emploi pour les jeunes une
enveloppe inédite de 6,5 milliards
d'euros en est déjà à disposition et je
peux dire à la représentation nationale
que déjà sur les primes à l'embauché sur
l'apprentissage
nous constatons des résultats
significatifs l'apprentissage apr s est
effondré pour les raisons que vous savez
au premier semestre est déjà remonté à
nout 2020 à ce qu'il était à nout 2019
les entreprises les entreprises seront
soutenus nous avons raison de le faire
et nous devons être fiers de le faire
pour tenir leur carnet de commandes
monsieur le président pour accélérer
leur transformation numérique écologique
et indépendante
nous devons c'est un devoir de le faire
quant aux impôts aux impôts de
production auquel vous avez fait
allusion
permettez moi de redire à la
représentation nationale
deux éléments deux éléments le député le
premier ils bénéficieront à hauteur de
75%
non pas aux grands groupes comme vous
l'avez dit mais aux pme tpe et 1 t i et
vous le vérifierez de ses vrais deuxième
deuxième observation ses impôts de
production bénéficieront au secteur
industriel
combien de fois sur tous les bars et en
particulier sur les vôtres at on
légitimement demander que l'on
réinvestissent l'industrie nationale
et bien c'est l'un des objectifs majeurs
de se plaindre la merci monsieur le
premier ministre la parole est à
monsieur françois bour peuvent merci
monsieur dans ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères depuis maintenant trois jours
la région du haut karabagh de son nom
arménien laksar est sous le feu d'une
très violente agression militaire de
l'azerbaïdjan d'une ampleur inégalée
depuis la fin de la guerre de 94 7
provinces arméniennes fut comme vous le
savez arbitrairement rattacher la
république socialiste soviétique
d'azerbaïdjan turcophones par staline en
en gage de bonne volonté à l'égard de la
turquie naissante successeur de l'empiré
ottoman et sur les plaies béantes du
génocide des arméniens
après de violents programme entière
maignien dans les principales villes
azerbaïdjan et la suite de la
proclamation de l'indépendance du
haut-karabakh
lors de la chute de l'union soviétique
les arméniens ont dû lutter à nouveau
pour leur survie de 91 à 1994 sur ce
petit territoire montagneux aux confins
de l'arménie facteurs extrêmement
inquiétant dans cette guerre de haute
intensité qui se déroule aux portes de
l'europe la turquie joue un rôle
destructeur et profondément
déstabilisateur
par l'impulsion belliqueuse qu'elle
apporte au régime d'aliev dans cet
aventurisme guerrier meurtrier par son
soutien logistique et militaire directe
et même par la reconversion si l'on ose
dire de mercenaires syrien directement
sur le terrain il est indispensable que
la france s'engage sans délai pour faire
cesser l'agression de réservation et de
la turquie pour permettre un retour à la
table des négociations des représentants
du haut karabagh qui était signataire du
sexe de l'accord de cessez le feu en
1994 et pour appuyer la reconnaissance
du droit à l'autodétermination du haut
karabagh et la définition de son statut
juridique international final seule
garantie de sa sécurité de sa survie
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre quelles initiatives vous allez
prendre
par ailleurs de nombreuses collectivités
locales françaises aussi les charte
d'amitié avec des villes de laksar et
dans le contexte actuel
elles vont bientôt envoyer des aides
alimentaires des médicaments du matériel
médical pour les populations durement
touchés j'espère que cette fois les
préfets de la république ne les
empêcheront pas pouvez vous monsieur le
ministre nous en donner la garantie
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la république
merci je laisse la parole à monsieur
francis terre ministre délégué auprès du
ministre des affaires étrangères
l'europe
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député pupponi je tiens
d'abord à présenter les excuses de jean
yves le drian qui est en voyage comme
vous le savez avec le président de la
république dans les pays baltes vous
avez raison la situation est grave dans
le haut-karabagh les informations que
nous recevons font état de dizaines de
victimes dizaines de morts centaines de
blessés la crise est grave
la france est totalement mobilisée pour
trouver une si tu es une sortie à cette
crise puisqu'elle est grave pour
l'arménie elle est grave pour
l'azerbaïdjan mais elle est grave aussi
pour la stabilité de la région et la
paix dans la région
comme vous le savez peut-être pas mais
le président de la république a appelé
dès dimanche le premier ministre
arménien monsieur pashinian et le
président d'azerbaïdjan monsieur alief
pour appeler à la seo cessez le feu
immédiat
nous assumons dans ce contexte les
responsabilités toute particulière qui
sont les nôtres puisque comme vous
l'avez dit en 94
à la fin du conflit
la france a accepté le mandat de l'eau
et ce2 co présidé le groupe de minsk
avec la russie et les etats unis
d'amérique pour essayer de trouver une
solution diplomatique à la crise du haut
karabagh à la demande du président de la
république donc des échanges continus
ont lieu en ce moment même entre les
trois coprésidents en lien avec les
protagonistes pour trouver les voies du
cessez-le-feu et du retour à la
négociation
cette négociation qui doit permettre de
trouver une crise dure à une sortie de
crise durable à ce qui se passe depuis
des dizaines d'années comme vous l'avez
rappelé au karabagh dans le cadre du
droit international vous pouvez compter
sur la france pour travailler avec toute
la mobilisation qui est la sienne à
cette sortie crise je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole de
monsieur jean louis pierot
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'intérieur
il est arrivé du pakistan de manière
irrégulière en se déclarant mineurs
un juge a validé cette prétention le 24
septembre
c'est avec un hachoir qu'il a remercié
le pays qui l'avait accueilli en fait il
avait 25 ans ce périple criminels met en
lumière les carences du traitement des
mn à plus de 40 milles selon l'adf un
chiffre multiplié par trois depuis 2016
à leur majorité ils obtiennent quasi
automatiquement un titre de séjour ce
statut protecteur est impuissante appel
d'air pour les trafiquants d'êtres
humains c'est aussi une incitation à la
fraude dans le département de
seine-et-marne dont j'ai été le
président il avoisine les 80% et votre
loisy l'immigration adoptée en 2008 en
2018 qui élargit le regroupement
familial est une folie monsieur le
ministre que comptez vous faire pour
endiguer ce flux fidèle à sa tradition
d'humanité la france doit accueillir
dignement les mineurs qui se trouvent
sur son sol
mais pour s'assurer qu'il s'agit bien de
mineurs il faut que le refus de se
soumettre à un test d'âge se constituent
une présomption de majorité pour
décourager les réseaux de passeurs
il faut que l'attribution d'un titre de
séjour à la majorité ne soit qu'une
exception justifiée par le droit d'asile
ou un parcours exceptionnel
d'assimilation
seriez vous prêt à agir en ce sens ne
pas inciter de jeunes mineurs à quitter
leur famille et leur pays
c'est l'humanisme français ne pas les
laisser tomber entre les mains des
réseaux mafieux c'est l'humanisme
français l'heure est à l'action
merci monsieur député la parole
comme monsieur gérald darmanin ministre
de l'intérieur c'est le président même
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député thiero c'est parce que vous étiez
c'est parce que vous étiez président
d'un conseil départemental et que vous
connaissez la difficulté de cette
question et c'est parce que vous êtes
élu depuis un certain temps que vous
savez qu'elle est difficile et vous
auriez pu poser la même question d'un
gouvernement précédent puits précédents
où il y aurait eu un débat où monsieur
mariani aurait évoqué les tests adn et
vous n'avez toujours pas réglé
collectivement la question tant elle est
difficile parce que l'accueil sur le sol
national de gens parfois persécutés dans
leur pays parfois isolés de leur famille
parfois fraudeurs parfois n'étant pas
majoritaire
quand je pensais que la question était
grave monsieur jacob et qu'il méritait
pas de politicaillerie
vous auriez considérer monsieur theuriau
qu'effectivement il y avait le drame des
mineurs isolés dans notre pays
d'abord de ce qui mérite vous l'avez
tout à fait dit le droit d'asile
l'accueil de la république et ceux qui
méritent d'être reconduits à la
frontière parce que effectivement soit
ils ne sont pas mineurs soient ils
doivent repartir dans leur pays alors
dans votre démonstration permettez-moi
dire que le parallèle que vous avez fait
que l'attentât ignoble de vendredi
dernier n'est pas tout à fait juste
le préfet du val d'oise et le
département ont fait leur travail et le
test se et s est refusée par le juge
mais le test se vous le savez bien n'est
pas à 100%
bon et c'est aussi pour cela qu'il a été
refusée pour les juges il ya aujourd'hui
il ya aujourd'hui un drame des mineurs
isolés notamment venant du maroc
notamment venant de l'algérie mais aussi
de la tchétchénie ou du pakistan
je me rends au maghreb la semaine
prochaine à la demande du premier
ministre et du président de la
république pour régler le problème qui
relève notamment des pays du maghreb qui
est l'essentiel des primes que nous
faisons et j'attends également les
propositions de la semaine nationale
tous groupes confondus pour que dans les
prochaines mois que nous aurons à
discuter
elles seront bientôt à l'ordre du jour
nous puissions me suis regardé ce et moi
même avons été saisis mettre fin au
moins à la discussion autour de la
résolution de majorité parce
qu'effectivement c'est inacceptable
c'est faux majeures prennent la place
des vrais mineurs que nous devons
protéger ministre la parole de monsieur
jean michel fauvergue
merci monsieur le président ma ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur
la tarte l'attaqué survenue rue nicolas
appert à paris vient nous rappeler que
la réalité terroriste est toujours
présente sur notre sol national
à l'heure du procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 c'est charlie hebdo qui
était visé par un assaillant qui
semblait ne pas être au courant du
changement dans la presse du journal
ce qui serait risible si ça n'était pas
si grave car des blessés sont à déplorer
c'est à eux et à leurs proches que nous
parce nous pensons avant tout
je veux aussi saluer la célérité de
l'intervention des policiers qui a
permis l'arrestation du terroriste
policiers gendarmes quelquefois durement
mis en cause par une minorité de
détracteurs par une minorité de
détracteurs ont prouvé une fois de plus
leur efficacité et leur engagement au
service de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et quelquefois au péril de
leur vie
comme ce fut le cas dimanche à saint
denis que ces policiers et gendarmes en
soit mille fois remercier
un début de polémique est née du fait
que la rue nicolas-appert n'étaient pas
gardés par la police
on sait que les forces de sécurité sont
plus utiles à la protection des vies
plutôt que la protection des bâtiments
mais je veux bien admettre que
symboliquement n'importe où que de
manière symbolique ou d'importance
vitale des certaines certains lieux
peuvent être peuvent nécessiter une
vigilance statique dans le rapport que
nous avons rendu au premier ministre
avec ma collègue alice tour en 2018 nous
préconisions pour ce type de mission
entre autres une meilleure coopération
des différences des différentes formes
de sécurtié qu'elle soit régaliennes
municipal ou privés pour décharger les
premières au profit des seconds
monsieur le ministre avec votre soutien
et avec celui du gouvernement
quand allons-nous pouvoir transformer
ces propositions qui ont recueilli un
large consensus auprès des populations
et les professionnels en outils
législatifs
je vous remercie merci je ferai la
parole à monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur député fauvergue
permettez moi tout d'abord moi aussi de
remercier les forces de secours les
policiers qui sont intervenus et qui en
moins d'une heure ont su arrêter dans
une foule l'auteur
le terroriste islamiste qui a essayé
d'attenter à la vie de deux personnes
effectivement rua père vendredi dernier
ces policiers ont fait montre d'un grand
sang froid et je crois que nous n'avons
absolument rien me semble-t-il sur ses
dents et ailleurs à leur reprocher
puisque tous les jours ils font un
travail dans des conditions difficiles
et ce matin les cérémonies nous avons pu
faire avec madame la maire de paris qui
rappelle le sacrifice d'un mètre merabet
tu es de cet officier du sdlp qui a
protégé les jeunes charlie et qui sont
morts sous les coups des théories sista
liste nous démontre qu effectivement
l'hommage que vous leur rendez et digne
de la représentation nationale
vous avez évoqué monsieur le député les
nécessaires tâche que nous devons
simplifier voire supprimées parfois pour
la police nationale pour la gendarmerie
pour la laisser se concentrer sur le
véritable police dont on a besoin pour
la police nationale pour la gendarmerie
la lutte contre les stupéfiants
le trafic d'armes les crimes de sang et
bien évidemment la lutte contre le
terrorisme et c'est dans cet esprit que
c'est avec joie
monsieur le député comme avec ce que
porte votre collègue madame tour au que
si l'assemblée nationale met à l'ordre
du jour je crois que cela peut arriver
dans les prochaines semaines
la proposition de loi que vous évoquez
le gouvernement il donnera un avis
favorable pour améliorer le continuum de
sécurité nous permettra d'ailleurs à
paris de créer la police municipale
proposées par monsieur griveaux par
monsieur maillard et par d'autres
parlementaires ici pour qu'on puisse
libérer les policiers nationaux à sa
tombe de tâches que l'on pourrait
appeler quotidienne et poids renforcé un
certain nombre de dispositifs en faisant
confiance au maire par leur police
municipale pour permettre à la police
nationale de travailler encore davantage
sur les grandes questions de sécurité
nationale que vous évoquez alors oui
monsieur député fauvergue
nous avons hâte au gouvernement de
travailler avec vous pour faire adopter
votre loi merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur bastien le show
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre vous êtes en train de
susciter la pagaille sanitaire vos
consignes sont incompréhensibles votre
communication illisibles les règles
changent tous les jours et on ne sait
plus à quel endroit elle s'applique
comment les français peuvent-ils s'y
retrouver comment pourrait-il les
appliquer comment pourrait-il les
accepter pourtant depuis le début de
l'épidémie
les français ont fait la preuve de leur
civisme l'ensemble des forces politiques
a fait preuve de responsabilité
mais comment faire quand on ne comprend
plus rien les rassemblements de dix
personnes sont interdits mais nous
continuerons nous on ainsi dans les
transports en commun on peut aller au
travail à l'école à l'université mais
pas faire du sport on veut boire un
verre ou aller au restaurant mais pas
après 22h vous fermer les bars à
marseille pour le vendredi soir puis
finalement pour le dimanche
stop qu'ovide et larmes ultime contre la
pandémie
mais le premier ministre ne l'a pas
télécharger
voulez-vous qu'on s'y retrouve plus de
24 heures après les annonces du ministre
de la santé le site du gouvernement
n'était même pas encore actualisé les
préfet prennent des arrêtés
contradictoires du jour au lendemain
les maires sont désemparés et ne savent
que faire dans ces conditions il ne faut
pas s'étonner que les français
désobéissent c'est vous qui en porter la
responsabilité
c'est vous qui s'appelle autorités de
l'état c'est vous qui sape et le
consentement à la loi fondements de
notre république parce que vous gérer au
jour le jour
comme l'a dit olivier ferrand au lieu de
planifier or sans visibilité sans
explication pas de confiance pas de
consentement
monsieur le premier ministre nous ne
voulons pas le cas aux sanitaires
nous voulons pouvoir obéir à des
consignes sanitaires rationnelle clair
et compréhensible
nous voulons la planification de la
riposte à la crise sanitaire et à la
crise sociale que comptez vous faire
la parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député bastien la chaux
merci de me donner deux minutes pour
revenir sur la pédagogie de la stratégie
nationale qui est en vigueur depuis plus
de sept mois dans notre pays mais qui
est d'ailleurs assez analogue à la
plupart des stratégies de lutte contre
l'épidémie en vigueur dans les pays
voisins
quand je parle de stratégie nationale
monsieur le député je pense que vous
l'avez compris puisque nous l'avons
répété un grand nombre de fois stratégie
nationale n'est pas opposé à déploiement
territorial la différenciation par
exemple quand le virus circule beaucoup
et que les mesures de freinage du virus
sont nécessaires nous proposons aux
couples maires préfets de mettre en
place des mesures de freinage pour
freiner la diffusion du virus et
permettre au territoire de retrouver de
la sérénité du point de vue économique
c'est ce que nous avons fait en guyane
avec succès c'est ce que nous avons fait
en mayenne avec succès c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de faire dans un certain
nombre de territoires avec déjà des
signes de réduction de l'épidémie par
ailleurs il est des territoires dans
lesquels le virus circule que voire très
peu et bien c'est tant mieux
et dans ce cas là nous appliquons là bas
les mesures qui s'appliquent à tout le
monde c'est à dire le respect des
gestes-barrières la limitation des
prises de risques des prises de risque
le tracé tester isolé quand c'est
nécessaire et la protection des plus
vulnérables
une stratégie nationale une application
locale en fonction de la sévérité vous
savez nous publions au quotidien à la
demande du président de la république
l'ensemble des indicateurs qui guide nos
décisions et ces décisions nous ne
prenons pas tout seuls leurs vins coin
nous les prenons en concertant la
représentation scientifique médical de
votre pays en concertant les élus on a
parlé d'une métropole dans lesquelles
les il a été compliqué pendant les
premières heures je me suis rendu à
marseille les choses se sont arrangées
la compréhension été rétablie de faire
comprendre les choses mais j'ai appelé
huit maires et huit présidents de
métropole monsieur le député qui ont
toutes en toute responsabilité accepté
les mesures les ont accompagnés qu'il
soit de gauche ou de droite et je veux
saluer cet esprit républicain
le meilleur moyen d'inciter les français
à respecter les règles c'est de dire que
les règles on les comprend qu'elles sont
bonnes et que je portais qui existe doit
les respecter
mais le trouble c'est ce que vous faites
à votre question le député mr sim
[Applaudissements]
sur le show
strub je suis désolé vous ne répondez
pas vous ne répondez pas vous ne
répondez pas à la question
la question n'est pas là la gestion
décentralisée la question est
qu'aujourd'hui les maires les préfets ne
sont même pas informés de ce que vous
leur demandez et surtout que les
français ne peuvent pas comprendre c'est
incompréhensible je suis désolé pourquoi
le ministère le site du ministère a mis
plus de 24 heures à inscrire les données
que vous aviez dit oralement tous parce
que personne ne s'y est prise de la
parole est à monsieur benoit poterie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des solidarités et
de la santé
monsieur le ministre je ne vais
peut-être pas mourir du coc vide mais si
ça continue je vais mourir d'ennui
cette phrase nous l'avons tous entendue
de multiples fois notamment de la part
de personnes âgées
ces mêmes personnes que nous cherchons à
protéger du virus à l'image de ses
seniors
les français ont tout accepté avec
beaucoup de sang froid les mesures
sanitaires
puis le confinement du printemps dernier
ils ont ensuite accepté les restrictions
qui leur sont imposées depuis le
déconfinement parce qu'ils en mesure la
nécessité mais alors que se profile la
possibilité d'une deuxième vague et tout
en connaissant les contraintes qui sont
les vôtres monsieur le ministre
le groupe agir ensemble vous demande
aussi de rassurer les français
depuis quelques jours les nouvelles
interdictions décrété par le
gouvernement provoque une vague de
défiance de la part de nos concitoyens
les restaurants les bars ou encore les
salles de sport qui ont pour la plupart
joué le jeu de la distanciation et des
gestes barrières ne comprennent pas
qu'on leur impose des interdictions
supplémentaires alors qu'ailleurs des
rassemblements non encadrés ont bien
plus d'impact sur la propagation du
virus
la santé de nos concitoyens est une
priorité et nous sommes conscients de la
gravité de la situation
mais plutôt que de créer chaque jour de
nouvelles mesures ne faudrait-il pas
aussi mieux contrôler l'application des
mesures existantes le rôle de médecin et
de soigner de sauver des vies et de
prévenir les risques
mais notre rôle de politique et de
veiller à un juste équilibre entre la
protection des citoyens et le respect
des libertés
alors que nous nous apprêtons à voter la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
le groupe agir ensemble souhaiterait que
les mesures évoquées fasse l'objet d'un
véritable débat contradictoire à
l'assemblée nationale ce débat
permettrait aussi de faire le point sur
l'état des stocks des matériels destinés
à nous protéger et à protéger les
soignants et personnels y compris
intervenants à domicile pour éviter
l'aggravation de la situation sanitaire
alors monsieur le ministre seriez vous
favorable à débattre collectivement de
ces sujets complexes mais sinistre ils
auraient débuté les parents le cas
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député benoist poterie je vous remercie
pour votre pour votre question vous
poser la question de la légitimité en
tout cas la compréhension de certaines
mesures de restriction qui ont été mises
en place dans les territoires dans
lesquels le virus circule de plus pour
protéger la sécurité et la santé des
français
je si vous le permettez sortir quitter
les frontières nationales un instant
pour expliquer aussi à la représentation
nationale ce qui se passe pas très loin
de chez nous pas trop bien de chez nous
en angleterre le premier ministre
anglais vient d'appeler à un couvre-feu
à 22h sur tout le territoire sur tout le
territoire de l'ensemble des bars et
restaurants en disant que cette
situation risque de durer pour six mois
aux pays-bas
hier l'ensemble des bars et des
restaurants du pays ont été soumis une
mesure de couvre feu à 22 heures pour de
nombreuses semaines à venir a dit le
premier ministre des pays bas un peu
plus à l'est la hongrie maintient
toujours depuis le confinement des
mesures de couvre feu sur l'ensemble des
bars et des restaurants
je pourrais vous parler de l'espagne ou
alors à laquelle nous nous parlons plus
d'un million de madrilènes sont dans un
état d'une situation de confinement
généralisée tel que nous l'avions connu
je pourrais vous parler de l'italie ou
de l'allemagne où toutes les rencontres
sportives se tourne toujours à huis clos
depuis le mois de mars et dans certaines
régions italiennes où les enfants ne
récolte que deux jours par semaine
depuis le début du mois de mars dernier
je pourrais vous parler du portugal où
tous les rassemblements supérieure à 20
personnes sont interdits depuis des mois
je pourrais vous parler encore de
nombreux exemples israël qui est
toujours en confinement généralisé ou de
la grèce qui l'a toujours pas rouvert
ses salles de spectacle croyez bien
monsieur le député que la france ne
prend pas de mesures unilatérales
sont pas fondées sur une justification
sanitaires et scientifiques nous nous
concertons d'ailleurs par delà les
frontières
et lorsque vous appelez un débat
parlementaire dans le cas de la
prolongation des mesures transitoires de
sortie d' état d'urgence sanitaire
je serai présent dans l'hémicycle
évidemment pour que ces dames ce débat
apaisé important fondamentale même pour
que chacun puisse appréhender la
situation sanitaire est la réponse
démocratique se fasse dans les
meilleures conditions je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est un jeu maximino monsieur
le premier ministre russe que jamais se
rendre à un spectacle est devenu un acte
de résistance contre le virus alors que
les métiers qui les font vivre sont à
bout de souffle régisseur
administrateurs prestataire événementiel
acteurs et bien d'autres encore au total
plus de 350 mille personnes payent la
facture des incohérences gouvernementale
car comment comprendre qu ils soient
plus dangereux de se rendre dans une
salle de spectacle qui appliquent des
règles sanitaires strictes que d'être
entassés deux fois par jour dans les
transports en commun comment comprendre
que les organisateurs soient tenus pour
seuls responsables
là où la position gouvernementale a fait
l'objet de tant de revirements
successifs et que certains ministres
rejette toute responsabilité
comment comprendre qu'il soit plus
facile d'interdire que de contrôler et
de sanctionner des incompréhensions
générant une concentration et une colère
bien légitime qui ne se limitent pas
d'ailleurs au seul monde du spectacle
mais aussi aux salles de sport aux bars
et aux établissements de nuit qui sont
d'ailleurs en manifestation devant notre
assemblée
alors vous me direz que des mesures ont
été prises et qu'elles sont renforcées
dans le plan de relance mais c'est
ignorer la réalité du terrain qui
lorsque vous le consulter vous saute aux
yeux et dont le désespoir vous prend à
la gorge car la réalité est que les
aides ne parviennent seulement qu'à
couvrir à peine les charges mensuelles
que reste-t-il pour vivre la réalité est
que les cotisations ne sont pas annulés
mais juste reporté
que faire dans un an puisque l'activité
perdue ne sera jamais recréé la réalité
est que ces professions ces emplois sont
en train de s'éteindre
et pourtant ces talents font une chance
pour notre pays ils sont les
représentants d'une culture partout
envié qui rayonnait hier dans le monde
et qui demain ne seront plus qu'un
souvenir faute d'un soutien sur le long
terme
à la hauteur des enjeux alors monsieur
le premier ministre écoutez les entendez
les je vous remercie
merci monsieur minot la parole et à
madame roselyne bachelot ministre de la
culture monsieur le député maximino vous
avez raison d'insister sur le rôle
fondamental de la culture et vous avez
raison aussi d'insister sur le fait que
ce secteur de la culture a été gravement
touché c'est un des secteurs économiques
les plus importants pour notre pays
six cent cinquante mille emplois 80
mille entreprises et le gouvernement
s'est complètement mobilisée pour
soutenir pour soutenir ce secteur
le budget de la culture est en
augmentation de 4 8% et le plan de
relance consacre 2 milliards d'euros à
soutenir la culture
vous avez raison de dire que ce secteur
de la culture a été particulièrement
responsable il a été particulièrement
responsable en respectant avec une
grande précision une grande
responsabilité
les mesures sanitaires port du masque
tout le long du spectacle respect des 10
dès distanciation physique entre les
spectateurs mise à disposition de gel
hydro alcoolique qui a permis de
préserver la santé à la fois des
spectateurs mais aussi des acteurs et
des techniciens qui se déploie alors
nous allons nous déployer d'abord sur
l'urgence qui va continuer nous avons un
fonds de 100 millions d'euros dégagés
pour soutenir la billetterie est bien
entendu à la fois dans le plf dans le
projet de loi de finances et dans les
dents le plan de relance vous avez à la
fois des mesures d'urgence et des
mesures de refondation prend deux
exemples 200 millions d'euros pour le
secteur de la musique 165 millions
d'euros pour le secteur du cinéma
jamais jamais on a fait autant pour le
secteur de la culture
moi je lui fait confiance c'est quelque
chose d'absolument à 10
ça pour notre pays nous nous en donnons
les moyens merci madame la ministre
monsieur minots merci monsieur le
président à écouter madame la ministre
je ne doute pas en tout cas de votre
bonne intention mais aujourd'hui elles
ne suffisent plus et rien n'est pire que
des espoirs déçus
donc nous comptons en tout cas sur le
gouvernement pour que la culture ne soit
vraiment pas oublié parce qu'aujourd'hui
elle est pris à la gorge
merci monsieur députés la parole est à
monsieur yannick favennec bécaud merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au nom du nouveau groupe des
démocrates à madame la secrétaire d'état
en charge de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement festival reporter fête de
village à nu les assemblées générales
différé trésorerie est asséchée
nos associations quelle qu'elle soit
ainsi que leurs bénévoles traverse
depuis mars dernier une crise sans
précédent je le constate chaque jour
dans notre chère région des pays de la
loire madame la ministre alors qu'elles
sont le socle du bien vivre ensemble
alors qu'elle contribue à l'animation l
attractivité nos territoires
alors que beaucoup d'entre elles
rencontrent de plus en plus de
difficultés nos associations
s'interrogent sur leur avenir et leur
pérennité
les adhérents vont ils renouvelé leur
cotisation les bénévoles vont ils
continuer à s'investir les emplois
associatifs pourront-ils être
sauvegardés
le public sera-t-il fidèle au prochain
et hypothétique rendez vous madame la
ministre je vous c'est profondément
attaché aux 13 millions de français qui
se dévouent chaque jour avec générosité
et altruisme dans nos villes dans nos
quartiers dans nos campagnes et nos
villages pour faire rayonner ce million
et demi d'associations qui forment le
ciment de nos valeurs républicaines
aujourd'hui plus que jamais ils ont
besoin que le gouvernement agisse vite
et concrètement avant que ce terreau
indispensables à l'épanouissement de la
vie citoyenne de notre pays ne se
décompose avant que cette formidable
ressource humaine qu'est le bénévolat ne
se tarisse madame la ministre
quelles mesures financières immédiates
entendez vous mettre en place
comptez-vous par exemples abondent et de
façon significative le fonds national de
développement de la vie associative
qui était censé remplacer la réserve
parlementaire je vous remercie merci je
ferai ma parole et à madame sarah herry
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et
l'engagement monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député yannick favenec bécaud vous
avez mille fois raison
nos associations elles ont tenu bon elle
ont elles ont elles se sont levés elles
ont résisté pendant cette crise
sanitaire et elles ont également pris de
pleine face
là les conséquences de cette crise les
conséquences elles sont de 2,2 de deux
formes de deux natures une nature
humaine et nature financière
il y en a qui n'ont pas pu faire les
festivals
il y en a qui ont fermé le rideau parce
que ce n'était pas possible il y en a
aussi qui ont vu arriver à leur porte
une partie de notre population qui a été
encore plus fragilisé je pense aux
banques alimentaires je pense aux
associations de solidarité sas et des
besoins financiers et il y a un vrai
besoin il y a un vrai appel
de l'autre côté il y a eu des
conséquences humaines nous avons des
bénévoles dont la moyenne d'âge est
grandissante
nous avons des bénévoles qui se sont
fatigués mais nous avons aussi l on l'a
vu une jeunesse qui s'est mobilisée
durant ce confinement et qui s'est
relevé les manches qui a répondu
présente pour répondre je crois qu'il ne
faut pas mettre de poussière sous le
tapis et répondre aux deux besoins le
premier c'est le besoin financier dans
le plan de relance il ya un milliard
d'euros au secteur par secteur qui a
accompagné par l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement pour répondre aux
associations de la culture aux
associations sportives vraiment secteur
par secteur
mais il n'est pas suffisant et c'est
aussi pour ça parce qu'il ya une urgence
immédiate de trésorerie qu'avec france
active qu'avec la banque des territoires
ces 100 millions d'euros en plus du plan
de relance qui sont déployés et qui vont
répondre à un besoin très concret
monsieur le député une association qui a
besoin de trésorerie
des fois la banque ne lui donne pas ne
lui ouvre pas cette ligne de trésorerie
eh bien demain avec france active c'est
le clean de trésorerie elle existera
jusqu'à 30000 euros à zéro euro à 0 pour
le taux d'intérêt c'est une réponse
concrète mais au-delà de là haut
au delà de ça il faut répondre aux
besoins humains aux besoins humains
c'est 15 millions d'euros pour de
l'emploi associatif c'est 7000 euros par
an pendant trois ans pour accompagner le
l'emploi associatif
celui-ci s'est aussi beaucoup monsieur
le député je sais que le débat
parlementaire aura lieu il sera vif faut
bien cibler le ministre la parole de
monsieur pierre dharréville monsieur le
ministre de la santé notre pays connaît
un regain épidémique inquiétant il
appelle une mobilisation augmenté dans
toute la société
c'est cette mobilisation que le
gouvernement doit s'attacher à provoquer
dans tous les domaines
or les mesures que vous avez annoncé la
semaine dernière ont suscité quand même
beaucoup de défiance et cela devrait
interroger la veille des annonces les
représentantes et représentants des
groupes et partis ont été réunies sans
apprendre grand chose
les maires n'ont pas été mieux associé
ni les acteurs sociaux et professionnels
nous ne croyons pas pour ce qui nous
concerne à la méthode verticale nous
traversons une épreuve qui affecte
profondément l'ensemble de nos vies nous
devons trouver les moyens d'une
résistance collective au virus qui
empêche le moins possible la poursuite
de la vie sociale et respecte les
libertés fondamentales et cela appelle
un effort d'autant plus puissant pour
être efficaces les mesures prises
doivent être largement acceptée et
appropriée et pour cela elles doivent
être cohérentes participative et
proportionnée la transparence doit
également être fait pour nous aider à
agir en toute conscience et lucidité et
ne pas se laisser gouverner par la peur
au moment nous sommes pourquoi ne pas
développer la présence de préventeurs et
préventes rice qui nous aide un peu
partout à prendre les bonnes précautions
quid de la relance d'une production
permettant de faire face aux besoins en
termes de respirateurs d'automates de
laboratoire
les tests doivent pouvoir jouer tout
leur rôle mais la question la plus
prégnante
monsieur le ministre c'est celle des
moyens de l'hôpital public beaucoup
auraient dû être fait depuis six mois
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs 3400 lui ont
fermé en 2019 4200 en 2018 où en
sommes-nous du nombre de lits
disponibles
où en sommes-nous des recrutements
merci monsieur le député la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député pierre dharréville merci pour
votre question vous êtes député des
bouches du rhône forcément je vais
essayer de répondre de joindre vos deux
questions sur les moyens de l'hôpital
en tout cas la préparation d'hôpital et
la situation sanitaire et la
compréhension des mesures en vous
parlant de marseille quand je suis allé
à marseille vendredi dernier j'ai emmené
avec moi des élus qui souhaitaient venir
notamment le président de la région nous
sommes allés dans une unité de l'hôpital
de la timone de réanimation nous avons
rencontré des dizaines de soignants
infirmiers et soignants médecins
professeurs dans l'unité dans laquelle
nous étions quatorze lits sur les quinze
dédiée à la prise en charge des malades
qu'ovide en réanimation étaient occupés
normalement cette réanimation elle sert
à accueillir des malades qui reçoivent
des opérations cardiaques ou
neurochirurgicale là il a fallu
commencer à rappeler des patients qui
devait être opéré du coeur ou du cerveau
pour leur dire qu'on ne pouvait pas les
opérer en l'état parce qu'on avait
besoin de plus de place de réanimation
je crois que ceux qui parmi les élus
sont venus visiter le service avec moi
en sont ressortis avec peut-être un
jugement un peu plus pondéré sur les
mesures qui ont été mises en place pour
protéger la santé des marseillais et
partout ailleurs protégé la la santé des
français et ensuite dans un amphithéâtre
ce sont des experts marseillais
épidémiologistes médecin réanimateur qui
était à mes côtés sur l'estrade pour
dire à la population que la situation
sanitaire était inquiétante qui ne
voulaient pas retarder davantage des
soins et que il appelait à ce que des
mesures soient prises et je pense que
cette prise de conscience monsieur le
député vous parlez de défiance c'est pas
la défiance et de la prise de conscience
qui a suivi l'annoncé de ces mesures
elles ne sont pas simples ces mesures et
personne ne dit qu'elles sont simples ni
à comprendre ni appréhender n'y a même à
supporter dans la durée elles sont
nécessaires monsieur le député elles
sont temporaires elles sont nécessaires
elles ne sont pas arbitraire elle vise à
sauver des vies et à protéger la santé
des marseillais et des français quant au
matériel de protection les équipements
de protection j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
communiquer nous avons de quoi soigner
les malades mais encore une fois nous ne
voulons pas
des blocs opératoires et les
réanimations donc on voulons continuer à
soigner tous les français et à soigner
les malades du co lead c'est pour ça que
nous luttons avec métairie nations comme
la situation sur istres la parole comme
monsieur doré ville pour quelques
secondes
merci monsieur le président je vous
rassure je suis également en contact
avec l'hôpital de mon territoire et
c'est vrai l'hôpital risque classiques
si vous avez raison c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous ai interrogé
précisément sur les recrutements en
sommes-nous sur le nombre de lits ou un
sens nous et vous ne m'avez pas répondu
je le regrette
merci monsieur débute la parole à
monsieur nicolas dupont aignan monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre
ma question s'adresse à vous je vous ai
écouté vous demander la confiance des
français
les pays qui surmontent la crise
sanitaire et économique sont ceux où le
peuple a confiance dans ses dirigeants
comment pouvons-nous avoir confiance en
vous et surtout les français à partir du
moment où depuis le début de la crise
mensonge succèdent aux mensonges
mensonges sur les masses pour masquer
l'incapacité mensonges sur les tests
pour masquer la désorganisation car des
tests dont les résultats sont huit jours
après n'ont plus aucun sens mensonges
sur les lits de réanimation car vous
n'avez pas profiter de l'été de
l'accalmie pour monter en puissance sur
la réanimation et rejoindre l'allemagne
mensonges aussi sur le plan économique
vous parlait tout le temps des 460
milliards mais sur les 300 milliards de
prêts exactement au 18 septembre
l'état a prêté 120 milliards sur les 100
milliards du plan de relance il y en a
que 35 milliard d'inscrits mensonges sur
le plan européen puisque le prennent le
le plan n'arrive toujours pas et il
arrivera trop tard et nous coûtera deux
fois plus cher alors moi je vous pose
trois questions concrètes
si vous voulez que les français aient
confiance en vous et bien prenez des
décisions réelle première décision
rattraper l'allemagne en matière de lits
de réanimation en rouvrant les hôpitaux
que vous avez fermé où les gouvernements
précédents ont fermé
deuxième point fondamental supprimer les
charges sociales du deuxième trimestre
des artisans commerçants et pme qui sont
face à un mur de dette vous
mu est toujours troisième point doubler
le plan de relance pour atteindre le
niveau de l'allemagne qui a un plan de
relance deux fois supérieur à caen alors
que la baisse du produit intérieur brut
est deux fois inférieur j'attends votre
réponse
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député dupont aignan je vois que votre
campagne présidentielle commence un peu
à l'instar de la précédente gageons
qu'elle finira la même manière dans la
provocation et l'outrance
je note que vous appelez à double plan
de relance monsieur dupont-aignan ça
veut dire qu'un élément de votre
programme a dû changer c'est que vous
voilà désormais pro européen puisque
sans l'europe une ré pas eu de plan de
relance de 100 milliards d'euros annoncé
par le président de la république et le
gouvernement voilà une bonne nouvelle
et je vous invite à un doute changer
votre site internet parce que mes propos
pro européens ne sont pas encore légion
je me permets de vous répondre
maintenant sur le fond et la préparation
de l'hôpital et des moyens mis à
disposition de l'hôpital et je vais vous
répondre par l'exemple ce qui permettra
de compléter la réponse que je n'ai pas
terminé pour monsieur le député pierre
dharréville ce que nous faisons pour
l'hôpital dans la situation de marseille
s'est mobilisée 360 millions d'euros
pour construire un bâtiment flambant
neuf mère-enfant moderniser sécuriser et
reconstruire du bâti de manière sans
précédent pour l'ensemble des hôpitaux
de marseille
avec le soutien de l'ensemble des
collectivités c'est un projet porté par
l'état et les collectivités dont les
travaux vont pouvoir commencer très vite
ce que nous faisons pour l'hôpital
séquence et en checkant j'avais pu
annoncer 15 millions d'aidants
trésorerie à l'hôpital de marseille pour
faire face à la crise sanitaire et que
j'ai rajouté deux millions d'euros nous
avons rajouté deux millions d'euros de
crédits supplémentaires pour aider les
réanimations à se moderniser ce que nous
faisons pour préparer l'hôpital c'est le
ségur de la santé ces 4000 lits qui vont
être rouverts dans l'hôpital partout où
c'est nécessaire
ce sont quinze mille soignants de plus
qui vont être embauchés nous allons donc
arrêter une spirale infernale vieille de
20 ans monsieur le député qui consistait
à faire toujours moins pour l'hôpital
maintenant nous allons faire toujours
plus par tous est nécessaire parce qu'il
en va de la sécurité sanitaire pour les
français voilà notre programme peut se
dit pour lorient
monsieur le député vous répondez aux
questions par la polémique et vous
mentez à nouveau car tous les cesse de
services hospitaliers savent que
l'hôpital public aujourd'hui est moins
bien disposés qu'il ya six mois et vous
n'avez pas pris les mesures qui
s'imposaient pour rouvrir les hôpitaux
fermés je pense au val de grâce pas
besoin de construire un hôpital il y à
des services monsieur le député la
parole est à madame laurence maillard
meniri merci monsieur monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
me dérangeait rabat secrétaire d'état à
la biodiversité madame la ministre la
question du bien être animal est une
préoccupation croissante de notre
société députés élus locaux citoyens
associations de citoyens
nous sommes largement sensibilisé
attentifs à cette problématique
nous sommes nombreux sur ses bancs être
mobilisés à travailler activement sur
ces questions et nous savons que le
gouvernement s'est engagé à agir
concrètement en faveur du bien-être
animal des actions concrètes ont déjà
été mises en oeuvre notamment dans et
galim et par le gouvernement dans le
secteur agricole puisque des
expérimentations de la vidéosurveillance
dans les abattoirs peuvent être déjà
réalisé la mise en production de tous
nouveaux bâtiments d'élevage de poules
pondeuses en cages est interdite comme
le seront d'ici 2021
la castration à vif des porcelets ou le
broyage des poussins au-delà de ces
mesures il ya une mobilisation
croissante est plusieurs à sand forte de
la part des associations et de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et il est
une autre de notre devoir de
parlementaire de reuil et relayer ses
attentes qui ne concerne pas seulement
le domaine agricole
il s'agit notamment de la question des
conditions de captivité des animaux
sauvages dans les cirques itinérants et
les delphinariums une large concertation
a été lancée avec les professionnels et
des solutions pérennes vont être
trouvées pour mettre fin aux conditions
inadaptées que subissent certains
animaux sauvages en captivité ce matin
madame barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique annoncé plusieurs
mesures fortes et ambitieuse en faveur
de la protection de la faune sauvage
captive
aussi pourriez vous nous préciser
quelles sont ses principales mesures
ainsi que les mesures concrètes pour
accompagner les professionnels de ces
filières merci merci la parole à
mélanger rabat secrétaire d'état chargé
de la biodiversité
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
députée et laurence meyer méhaignerie
vous l'avez dit cette cette conscience
très vive cette attention particulière
au bien être animal et notamment dans le
cadre des espèces sauvages et de la
faune aux captives
cette conscience a grandi dans nos
esprits depuis longtemps mais
certainement renforcée par la période
que nous venons de vivre cette crise
sanitaire lie à une zoonose qui nous a
rapprochés certainement des éléments de
la nature des espèces et du vivant
peut-être on nous rend en nous rappelant
que nous en faisons partie et donc cette
attention est aujourd'hui d'autant plus
vive
aujourd'hui nous avons effectivement
avec la ministre pompili fait quelques
annonces en ce sens qu'ils sont le fruit
de plusieurs années maintenant de
concertation et de réflexion au sein du
gouvernement qu'ils doivent nous amener
en connaissance des besoins
physiologiques de ces différentes
espèces à voir évoluer les pratiques et
les métiers de certaines personnes qui
en vivent
nous avons à l'issue de ces
concertations avec les associations les
professionnels les experts les élus nous
avons élaboré un plan de transition en
faveur du bien-être de la faune sauvage
captive avec un principe clé qui est
évident c'est l'accompagnement de cette
transition
d'abord dans les cirques itinérants la
détention d'espèces sauvages doit être à
terme interdite
alors nous sommes pour certaines
espèces typiquement les delphinariums
entre les orques et les dauphins sur des
pâtes des pâtes temps de transition de
deux à sept ans mais qui doivent nous
permettre effectivement à terme de ne
plus voir ce type de d'enfermement pour
ces espèces
nous travaillons par exemple dans le
cadre des espaces protégés à préserver
des sanctuaires et tout ce travail doit
se faire vraiment cet accompagnement
doit doit se faire avec les personnes en
contact nous avons sur l'élevage de
vison d'amérique et notamment pour la
production de fourrure des dispositions
également importante pour interdire à
terme ce type de ce type d'exploitation
avec une une question qui est évidente
liés aux espèces envahissantes exotisme
et la parole et à madame isabelle
santiago
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
dimanche dernier l'armée azerbaïdjanaise
a lancé une attaque militaire massive
contre la république du artsakh les
bombardements dans la capitale et ses
attaques d'artillerie ont notamment
touché des populations civiles dont des
enfants
c'est d'ailleurs la deuxième
recrudescence du conflit en moins de six
mois après les combats de juillet
dernier
de plus alors que le président erdogan
se fait de plus en plus menaçant pour
les européens
nous rappelons que le soutien politique
et militaire inconditionnels de la
turquie à l'azerbaïdjan porte une
responsabilité importante dans la
gravité de la situation actuelle
monsieur le premier ministre
la réaction de la france co présidente
du groupe de minsk doit être immédiate
et sans faiblesse et je veux le dire ici
nos accords commerciaux ne peuvent pas
être l'alpha et l'oméga de notre
diplomatie
nous souhaitons aussi que le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu réagissent très
fortement dans cette région du caucase
monsieur le premier ministre nous
voulons compter pleinement sur la
détermination de la france à
dans ce sens pour terminer je veux
rappeler solennellement dans cette
assemblée
pour ma première question mon amitié et
mon soutien envers les habitants et la
république du artsakh du peuple arménien
monsieur le premier ministre vous dire
que j'y suis allé eco artsakh je vois
deux visages de femmes d'enfants et
d'hommes je vous remercie de la réponse
même si c'est une deuxième sur ce thème
puisque du coup mon collègue et ami
pupponi l'a fait aussi merci voilà la
députée la parole est à monsieur franck
riester ministre délégué auprès de mille
affaires étrangères de l'europe
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
isabelle santiago vous avez raison la
situation au karabagh est terrible il ya
des morts des morts civiles plusieurs
dizaines de morts des centaines de
blessés et la france est pleinement
mobilisée avec ses partenaires notamment
du groupe de minsk pour retrouver un
cessez-le-feu immédiat et retrouver le
chemin des négociations pour trouver une
sortie de crise à cette région du haut
karabagh la france avec les co
présidents russe et américain du groupe
de minsk est très mobilisé d'abord au
sein de l'ol c'est eux qui l'a mandaté
pour en 4 1994 pour trouver une sortie
de crise elle est mobilisée au sein du
conseil de sécurité et vous avez eu
raison de rappeler cette instance
puisque cet après midi même
les trois coprésidents ferons un point
au sein du conseil de sécurité sur leur
évaluation de la situation et des
propositions de sortie crise en europe
bien évidemment puisque vous savez que
au delà des trois coprésidents un
certain nombre de membres de ce groupe
de minsk eux sont européens je pense à
l'allemagne ou à l'italie
donc vous voyez la france mobilise toute
son énergie le prix en république lui
même comme je le rappelais tout à
l'heure a eu en ligne le premier
ministre arménien le président de
l'azerbaïdjan
jean yves le drian qui ne pouvait pas
être aujourd'hui présent puisqu'il
accompagne le président de la république
dans les pays baltes et mobilisé à son
niveau pour essayer de trouver au sein
du groupe de minsk qui est le meilleur
la meilleure institution pour répondre à
ces crises toutes les voies de sortie
cessez le feu immédiat et ensuite
négociations pour trouver une sortie de
crise en s'appuyant sur le droit
international
merci madame la députée merci monsieur
le ministre la parole est un monsieur
didier quentin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
une nouvelle fois le 4 octobre prochain
les calédoniens qui sont français depuis
1853 1853 sont appelés à choisir entre
la france où l'indépendance ce choix
engagent leur avenir mais aussi celui de
notre nation alors qu'ils ont toujours
été aux côtés de la france et notamment
lors des heures les plus sombres
on peut également penser que cette
indépendance serait destructrice du rêve
qui a bâti les 30 dernières années et
qu'elle serait illusoire au regard de la
richesse des sols et de la zone
économique exclusive avec tous les
appétits
que ne manquerait pas de susciter le
désengagement de la france notamment de
la part d'une grande puissance voisine
dont l'expansionnisme est déjà bien
visible dans la mer de chine et jusque
sur les bords du pacifique
au-delà de cette consultation qui oppose
et divise les calédoniens et porte les
germes du séparatisme
nous militons pour que le chemin d'un
avenir apaisé soit offert aux enfants du
caillou vous me permettrez de citer jean
paulhan la france et partout où l'on ne
renonce pas le groupe les républicains
souhaitent donc que la france la france
des droits de l'homme ne renonce pas en
nouvelle calédonie et y demeurent
car nous n'aimons pas ce qui rétrécit la
france
or l'on peut pas dire que nous ayons
beaucoup entendu le président de la
république et votre gouvernement sur ce
choix crucial pour l'avenir de la
nouvelle calédonie dans la république
alors monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous nous préciser la position du
gouvernement resté jusqu alors bien
silencieux merci monsieur de débuter la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député quentin vous l'avez dit dimanche
c'est un moment très important 180
milles et lectrices et lecteurs de
nouvelle calédonie seront appelés à se
prononcer sur l'avenir de ce territoire
en répondant je le rappelle à la
représentation nationale à cette
question voulez vous que la nouvelle
calédonie accès dans la pleine
souveraineté et deviennent indépendantes
je vous rappelle que cette consultation
est prévue par l'accord de nouméa signé
en 1998
je vous rappelle aussi qu'il s'agit de
la deuxième consultation après celle du
4 novembre 2018 qui avait conduit au
refus de l'indépendance 56,67 % des
suffrages exprimés très précisément
conformément à l'accord de 1998 qu'il
assignait l'état reste et restera je
cite impartiale au service de tous dans
l'organisation et le déroulement des
opérations référendaires
nous sommes tenus par notre parole et
nous la respectons notre priorité est
donc d'assurer aux calédoniens qu'ils
pourront voter librement et
dans les meilleures conditions je vous
indique que d'une part cette
consultation se déroulera en présence
des observateurs de l'onu et du forum
des îles du pacifique
d'autre part que la commission de
contrôle composée de magistrats
indépendants est déjà présente sur place
avec les quelque 250 délégués qu'elle a
recruté pour assurer le caractère
incontestable et impartial de ce scrutin
bien entendu impartiale ne veut pas dire
en retrait nous souhaitons notamment que
la participation soit la plus élevée
possible
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui nous a guidés
dans les différentes décisions que nous
avons pris ces dernières semaines
je vous précise que nous avons rouvert
pour une semaine la possibilité d'opter
pour un bureau de vote
délocaliser ce qui a permis à 883
personnes supplémentaires de bénéficier
de ce dispositif qui permet au total à
5800 électeurs de voter à nouméa
alors qu'elles sont inscrits dans les
îles loyauté l'île des pins et bennett
nous traitons au jour le jour les
difficultés liées aux procurations
réalisé depuis l'hexagone et depuis
l'étranger
c'était le sens également du déplacement
du ministre chargé des outre-mer le 6
août dernier déplacement certes à la
maison de la nouvelle calédonie à paris
puisque les conditions sanitaires ne lui
a pas permis d'aller sur place
le président de la république l'a
annoncé il s'exprimera après la
consultation de dimanche et j'ai déjà
indiqué que je prendrai l'initiative de
réunir les acteurs politiques
calédoniens au lendemain de cette
consultation référendaire
j'espère pouvoir le faire à paris mais
je ne vous cache pas que les conditions
sanitaires
nous inviterons peut-être à faire
évoluer des habitudes vieilles de trente
ans mais l'engagement de dialogue
incarné par la république sera maintenu
merci merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole de madame valérie 6 merci
monsieur prix merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur premier ministre initialement
annoncé pour 2019 le projet de loi sur
le grand âge et la perte d'autonomie a
déjà été reporté à la suite du conflit
social des gilet jaune
il est aujourd'hui encore des cas les
six rapports sont pourtant déjà sur la
table ce report désespère les
professionnels du secteur
rappelons que le nombre de français
dépendants devrait doubler chaque année
jusqu'en 2030 il y a donc à urgence à
intervenir si nous avons salué la
création juillet dernier d'une cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale
nous avons dès l'origine soulevé la
question de son financement
en effet nous ne pouvons nous permettre
sur un tel sujet d'en rester aux effet
d'annonce le rapport de laurent vacher
rendu le 20 le 14 septembre préconise
une série de prélèvements sur les
retraités ou des réductions d'avantagés
fiscaux pour trouver les 6 milliards
d'euros jugés nécessaires d'ici 2024
il prévoit notamment l'augmentation de
la csg des retraités pour atteindre 9,2
pour cent la hausse des droits de
succession ou encore la division par
deux du plafond du crédit d'impôt pour
les employeurs d'une aide à domicile
toutes ces propositions reviennent à
financer l'autonomie au détriment de nos
concitoyens ceci alors même que les
impôts sont censés ne pas augmenter
notre groupe vous propose plutôt de
financer l'autonomie par la chasse à la
fraude sociale
à la lumière des rapports de la cour des
comptes ou de celui de nathalie goulet
de carole grandjean la fraude sociale
est toujours difficile à chiffrer mais
le rapport de la commission denquête de
notre collègue pascal brindeau estimer
l'étendue de celle-ci de 14 à 45
milliards d'euros
ma question est donc simple monsieur le
premier ministre
accepteriez vous que la cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale ne soient
pas financées par des augmentations
d'impôts mais par la lutte contre la
fraude sociale
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame la députée valérie six merci pour
votre question qui porte sur les
modalités de financement de la cinquième
branche autonomie d'abord rappelé les
trois étapes importantes pour la
question de la perte d'autonomie
la première étape foule avait franchi
c'est la création de la cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale premier
élargissement du périmètre de la sécu en
termes de branche depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale
la deuxième étape c'est le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
nous en avons présenté les premiers
contours ce matin alors de la commission
des comptes de la sécurité sociale
et je peux vous donner quelques chiffres
que vous serez amenés je l'espère à
voter avec nous dans le cadre du plfss
premiers chiffres 1,4 milliards 1,4
milliard c'est l'équivalent de la hausse
de salaire pour les métiers du soin dans
tous les ehpad publics et privés de ce
pays c'est la mesure du ségur deuxième
chiffre 1,4 milliard et oui encore cette
fois ci c'est 1,4 milliards pour rénover
les ehpad moderniser le bâti investir
troisième chiffre 600 millions d'euros
c'est le budget du plfss consacrés à la
numérisation du secteur de la perte
d'autonomie
au total si vous comptez comme moi ce
sont 3 4 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dans le champ de
l'autonomie qui seront présentées aux
parlementaires dans le cadre du prochain
plfss
c'est bien c'est très important mais ça
ne suffit pas le troisième étage de la
fusée
ce sera la fameuse loi sur la perte
d'autonomie qui sera présenté bientôt en
conseil des ministres et présenté
ensuite aux parlementaires et qui
viendra majoré encore des mesures
notamment sur l'attractivité des métiers
le taux de recrutement d'encadrement etc
nous y travaillons avec brigitte
bourguignon qui est ministre délégué à
l'autonomie les pistes de financement le
rapport vaches et n'engage que son
auteur mais le rapport est important et
est intéressant il soumet plusieurs
propositions le gouvernement aura
bientôt à statuer sur les modalités de
financement puisque vous avez raison
quand on engage une dépense sociale il
faut des recettes et vous savez qu'une
boulot
à augmenter les impôts des français donc
nous aurons un débat qui sera également
transférée au parlement quant à la
fraude sociale madame la députée sans
doute sans doute qu'il ya certainement
assurément et de la fraude sociale
je vous conjure ne retenez pas l'idée
qu'il pourrait y avoir 40 milliards
d'euros de fraude sociale dans notre
pays par an aucun rapport crédible de la
cour des comptes ou des organismes de
tantale et merci monsieur le ministre la
parole à monsieur raphaël chine berger
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé dimanche
depuis hier matin à marseille et à
aix-en-provence les grilles des bars et
restaurants de la ville demeure baisser
les gérants de ces établissements et
leurs employés sont replongés dans une
inquiétante incertitude quant à leur
avenir
ils sont en colère et nous les
comprenons ces mesures brutales annoncé
sans concertation frappe d'une
profession qui essayaient de relever la
tête
au prix d'un travail acharné alors que
vous répétez depuis de longues semaines
qu'il nous faut apprendre à vivre avec
le virus
c'est précisément ce qu'ont fait les
restaurateurs ils se sont imposé des
règles nouvelles indispensable mais
contraignante
ils ont appris à vivre avec le virus
en réponse vous imposer des mesures
brutales qui font peser une ombre sur la
profession bien au delà d'aix-marseille
cette mesure est contestée car
incohérente
aucune étude sérieuse ne démontre que
c'est dans ces lieux que se font les
contaminations pour les bars les cafés
et les restaurants ou les discothèques
en préférant l'interdiction et la
fermeture à la responsabilité
vous cherchez à effrayer à diviser et à
faire peur aux français
là où votre rôle devrait être de
mobiliser et de responsabiliser il nous
faut à linverse engagé un mouvement fort
de soutien et de confiance
alliant protection et reprise de
l'activité comme nous le proposons en
passant temporairement la tva à 5 5%
la france n'est pas la france n'est pas
elle-même sans ses restaurants gérer la
crise en renoncer à notre identité ne
nous renforcera pas pire cela nous
éloignera les uns des autres
ajoutant à la distanciation physique
nécessaire une distanciation social
mortifère monsieur le ministre il nous
faut vivre malgré le virus
merci monsieur le député la parole à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
monsieur le député jeune berger d'abord
vous avez été je crois reçu par les
restaurateurs de temps en temps des
restaurateurs et des bars ont été reçus
par le premier ministre ce matin pour
expliquer toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement économique parce qu'il
est hors de question que la france
laisse qui que ce soit sur le bord du
chemin
ce n'est pas une mesure punitive ce
n'est pas une mesure sanction n'est pas
une mesure arbitraire
ce n'est pas une mesure durable c'est en
revanche une mesure nécessaire à un
moment clé de la diffusion du virus sur
notre territoire que nous sommes obligés
de prendre en responsabilité et j'ai
tout à l'heure en réponse un de vos
collègues parlementaires citées la liste
des pays qui ont déjà instauré un
couvre-feu titan même boris johnson en
angleterre qui vient d'annoncer un
couvre-feu dans les bars restaurants 22h
pour probablement six mois ce que nous
ne faisons pas et c'est ce que nous ne
souhaitons pas faire pourquoi les bars
et restaurants ce n'est pas pour nuire à
la vie sociale
ce n'est pas pour nuire à la vie sociale
vous savez nous avons eu le même débat
avant l'été sur les discothèques ou un
certain nombre de parlementaires m'avait
interpellé et j'expliquais que nous
n'avons rien nous l'avions rien contre
les discothèques et rien contre le fait
que les français aient envie de danser
pendant l'été ou même pendant le reste
de l'année mais qu'il ya des lieux où
quoi que vous fassiez quel que soit le
protocole sanitaire que vous mettiez en
place quand vous avez des lieux clos où
il ya des dizaines voire des centaines
de personnes qui n'ont pas de masse
parce qu'ils mangent ou qu'ils vont
boire
hélas et c'est pas la responsabilité des
chefs d'entreprise ou des artisans c'est
pas ça le problème
le problème c'est que toutes les
situations qui sont favorables à la
circulation du virus
des études internationales attestent
qu'il est entre deux et quatre fois plus
de gens qui se contaminent oco vide
quand ils ont fréquenté un bar ou un
restaurant la semaine précédente que
quand ils n'ont pas fait ce n'est pas le
gouvernement français qui a décidé de
mettre en place ce type d'indicateur
d'accord ici il s'impose à nous pour
limiter freiner la diffusion croyez moi
ces mesures sont proportionnelles du
rouleau
moins longtemps possible elles seront le
moins répandu possible sur l'ensemble du
territoire et à chaque fois que nous les
prendrons nous accompagnerons du premier
jour jusqu'au dernier l'ensemble des
personnes qui sont pénalisés dans leur
activité
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame clémentine autain bridgestone
1,8 million d'euros de cic eu 8 163
suppressions d'emplois general electric
30 millions dette publique
1225 suppressions de postes nokia 280
millions d' aide de l'état
1200 postes en moins sanofi 17 millions
de cice 125 millions de crédits d'impôt
mille emplois supprimés carrefour 149
millions d'euros grâce au cic eu 3000
salariés sur le carreau en 2019 air
france
9000 suppressions d'emplois à l'ordre du
jour mais le pdj rassurez-vous s'octroie
un bonus de 800 mille euros au titre de
son excellente gestion de l'année 2019
voilà à quoi servent les 90 milliards
d'euros de cic e et autres aides que
vous avez livré sans rien demander en
retour
or votre plan de relance consacre encore
10 milliards aux baisses d'impôts sur la
production toujours sans contrepartie
pendant ce temps une femme en famille
monoparentale est en pleurs dans une
permanence syndicale
un collègue confie préparer son suicide
la peur est le pire se trament face à la
vague des licenciements et la récession
économique
ces drames humains ne font que commencer
et ma question est simple c'est que
faites vous que faites-vous parce que
vos larmes de crocodile au chevet des
entreprises qui licencient n'arrive pas
à masquer l'indécence de vos choix
politiques
il faut exiger des comptes par la loi à
ce que vous arrosez de cadeaux fiscaux
il faut contraindre réglementé orienté
organisée et non servir les dividendes
et dépossédé l'état de ses capacités
d'agir ou et la puissance publique
capable de protéger les salariés de
garantir une sécurisation des parcours
professionnels
où est l'état stratège capable
d'enclencher la transition écologique de
prévoir
anisé l'économie en fonction de nos
besoins véritables et non de ceux du
capital
à quand le partage des richesses et des
temps de travail à quand le renoncement
à votre contre réforme du chômage et à
celle des retraites
merci mme le député la parole à madame
agnès pannier plus de chez ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
clémentine autain le travail de ce
gouvernement c'est tous les jours
d'aller lutter pour créer de l'emploi et
faire en sorte que de moins d'emplois
soit supprimée dans une crise qui est
aujourd'hui inédite mondial et qui a
conduit à détruire des millions
d'emplois dans les autres pays et je me
permets de d'ouvrir cette perspective le
travail de ce gouvernement c'est celui
qui a permis de créer cinq cent mille
emplois
lors de ce les trois premières années du
quinquennat
une performance que nous n'avons pas vu
depuis des années cinq cent mille
emplois madame hautain et ça je crois
que c'est la meilleure réponse que nous
pouvons faire justement à ces personnes
qui cherchent la dignité à ces personnes
qui cherchent l'autonomie c'est de le
remettre en main cette capacité à
construire elle-même leur vie les femmes
monoparentales qui doivent élever leur
enfant et qui ont besoin de ces emplois
alors permettez moi de vous dire que
plutôt que de rechercher des coupables à
un moment où certaines entreprises font
face à des baisses de carnet commandes
de 50 pour cent cinquante pour cent mais
da mota à un moment où ce gouvernement a
justement remis en cause le séisme
justement remis en cause mais cice je
crois qu'il faut plutôt construire est
notée l'action du gouvernement pour
accompagner un salarié sur deux dans le
privé pendant le confinement
un salarié sur deux pour mettre sur la
table plus de 123 milliards d'euros pour
les entreprises à 95 % pour les pme les
tpe
alors arrêtons la démagogie avec les
grandes entreprises celles 35
entreprises ont eu le pge
tong ou pour les pme les emplois et les
français merci madame la ministre
la parole comme chez guillaume chiche
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre adrian taquet aujourd'hui
encore la protection de l'enfance est un
enjeu fondamental pour notre société
la crise sanitaire que nous traversons a
plongé toutes les familles dans le
confinement
elle a placé à l'isolément l'ensemble
des enfants loin de leurs amis de
l'école et des activités extrascolaires
pour certains de ces enfants cela fut
synonyme d'épanouissement d'amour et de
protection mais pour les autres ce fut
le théâtre de souffrance psychologique
de coups de viol les appels au 119 ont
fortement augmenté durant cette période
témoignant d'adolescents et d'enfants en
grand danger les travailleurs sociaux de
la protection de l'enfance n'ont pas eu
la possibilité d'intervenir au sein des
familles ou d'accompagner correctement
les enfants et je tiens d'ailleurs à
saluer leur détermination singulièrement
dans le territoire que je connais le
mieux celui des deux sèvres pour leur
action quotidienne est exemplaire auprès
d'enfants meurtris par les violences
psychiques et psychologique
le confinement que nous avons subies a
mis en lumière les difficultés d'un
système à bout de souffle
nous ne pouvons plus accepter monsieur
le ministre que des enfants soient
laissés seuls
enfermé dans une chambre d'hôtel ou à la
rue en proie à la drogue à l'alcool aux
violences ou à la prostitution en temps
normal ce sont 75 % des appels passés au
119 qui ne sont pas traités du fait de
leur trop grand nombre
qu'en at il été durant le confinement
comment ont été détectés et traités les
informations préoccupantes
alors que les écoles les services
sociaux qui constitue un acteur clé au
sein des procédures de signalement ne
pouvait assurer leurs missions
l'invisibilité de la protection de
l'enfance doit cesser malheureusement
monsieur le ministre la stratégie
nationale de prévention et protection de
l'enfance n'a pas permis d'endiguer la
détresse alors pouvait vous prends
l'engagement devant la représentation
nationale de nous transmettre des
données factuelles chiffrées sur la
gestion de la protection de l'enfance
durant la période de confinement et nous
indiquer les moyens mis en place pour
répondre à un double objectif celui de
la résorption des détresses accumulée
pendant le confinement est celui de la
préparation en cas de confinement
partielle ou totale de la population je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
mme aubry attaque et secrétaires d'état
l'enfance et aux familles merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député guillaume si
je suis ravi de voir que vous
investissez désormais sur ce sujet la
protection l'enfance
ce sera l'occasion pour nous de
continuer ses conversations car il peut
être difficile de vous répondre en deux
minutes sur l'ensemble des questions
vous avez soulevés qui sont des
questions profondes et pertinente
j'étais très inquiet au moment du
confinement très inquiet pour les foyers
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance dont on
sait que ce sont des lieux où des
tensions dans déjà en temps normal
peuvent avoir peuvent avoir recours
alors même que l'école fermait vous
l'avez dit que les activités les
transferts avaient été avait été annulée
très inquiet aussi pour les familles
puisque vous savez que 80% des violences
faites aux enfants dans notre pays ont
lieu dans le cercle intrafamiliales et
nous renvoyons en fermant les écoles des
enfants dans leur dans leur famille
sachant que nous privions aussi de nos
yeux puisque l'éducation nationale est
le premier pourvoyeur des informations
préoccupantes
écoutez sans faire de généralité ayant
bien conscience qu'un centre de
situation était compliquée et je salue à
mon tour l'engagement et l'implication
des travailleurs sociaux sans lequel la
situation n'aurait pas été n'en ai pas
pu tenir un certain nombre de choses
assez contre-intuitif se sont passées ce
sont les acteurs de terrain qui nous ont
dit que j'ai eu toutes les semaines
durant le confinement que j'ai encore vu
la semaine dernière - de fugue moins de
violence entre les enfants et entre les
enfants et les éducateurs
pourquoi parce que plus de temps passé
autour de l'enfant moins de rapports
administratifs à remplir par les
travailleurs sociaux moins de
déplacements à droite et à gauche pour
aller chez le juge chez les parents à
l'école et ça doit nous inspirer
ça doit réinterroger nos pratiques et
sari interroge les pratiques des
travailleurs sociaux et nous sommes en
train notamment avec le conseil national
de la protection de l'enfance d'en tirer
les enseignements pour savoir ce que
nous allons en faire et puis dans les
familles vous l'avez dit augmentation
certaine semaines de 80 % des appels aux
119 qui s'est accompagnée d'une
augmentation de 40 % des appels par les
voisins de 40% par les petits copains
ce qui me laisse à penser et je veux
croire que c'est aussi l'instauration
d'un réflexe 119 et que nous sommes tous
nous avons tous été plus vigilants
pendant la le confinement à ce qui se
passait derrière la paroi de
l'appartement
c'est ce réflexe la queue
doit préserver aujourd'hui que nous
sommes sortis à paroles de monsieur jean
louis bricout
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et concerne le plan de
relance intégré au projet de loi de
finances pour 2021
mais une question me taraude monsieur le
ministre
où est la relance pas les verts a beau
nous le rappeler seuls 35 des 100
milliards d'euros annonçait l'été sont
inclus dans le budget 2021
un budget qui ne répond pas à l'urgence
de la situation
au début de cette crise sanitaire et
bien qu'il y ait eu quelques trous dans
la raquette sur les jeunes sur les
auxiliaires de vie aux dispositions
étaient quelque peu en phase avec la
situation du moment avec des mesures
comme le chômage partiel
ces mesures étaient nécessaires la
sauvegarde de l'emploi des entreprises
du pouvoir d'achat des ménages
en revanche avec votre plan de relance
vos mesures ne répondent pas à l'urgence
du moment
elle arrive déjà bien trop tard
les effets de vos mesures seront aussi
trop tardif
vous n'avez pour boussole que la
compétitivité des entreprises par la
baisse d'impôts qui n'auront d'effet que
pour les grandes entreprises
vous oubliez les tpe et les pme elles
doivent pourtant être soulagés de leur
dette qu'ovide de leurs charges et nous
devons aussi remplir leurs carnets de
commandes
pourtant l'ensemble des acteurs comme
l'insee ou la banque de france disent
que c'est la demande qui doit être
soutenu votre budget lui est
déséquilibré sur les 100 milliards celui
100 millions vont aux oubliés et au plus
impactée par la crise sociale
monsieur le ministre il y à une urgence
sociale et de pouvoir d'achat qui exige
une relance par la consommation
enfin sur les mesures d'investissements
écologiques
là aussi les crédits ne sont pas à la
hauteur pour la rénovation des logements
du parc privé par exemple on au niveau
des aides 2017 sur les investissements
sur les bâtiments publics ou les projets
portés par les collectivités
ces projets arriveront bien trop tard
cette crise inédite nécessite un plan de
relance aux effets immédiats
vous avez dès à présent plusieurs
longueurs de retard
monsieur le ministre où en est la
relance
merci chers collègues par le thème chez
olivier dussopt ministre chargé des
comptes publics merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député bricout de
questions dans votre question en réalité
et je vais répondre en deux points
où est la relance dites vous où est le
plan de relance 100 milliards d'euros
qui sont disponibles 100 milliards de
remporter pour l'unedic la caisse des
dépôts la banque des territoires havrais
14 milliards d'euros et 86 milliard
d'euros porté par l'état ouvert soit
sous forme d'autorisation d'engagement
dans le plf 2021 vous aurez à examiner
soit sous forme de baisses d impôts de
production comment est-ce que la relance
se mettent en oeuvre seulement neuf tout
de suite elle se met en oeuvre tout de
suite puisque grâce aux votes de la
majorité à l'occasion de la loi de
finances rectificative numéro 3 vous
avez voté l'assemblée nationale a voté
la prime pour l'embauché des jeunes elle
est disponible
vous avez voté la prime pour l'embauché
des apprentis elle est disponible
vous avez voté la prime pour la
conversion des parcs automobiles c'est
disponible aussi vous avez modifié les
critères pour permettre un plus grand
accès à ma prime rénove ses disponibles
nous avons mis en place des mesures
extrêmement important sur le chômage
partiel qui permettent de répondre à la
fois à la dimension sociale et on
maintenir les emplois et ce matin le
premier ministre a confirmé que les
secteurs les plus touchés pourrait
encore bénéficier d'un régime de chômage
partiel particulièrement favorable pour
les accompagner face à la crise est-ce
que nous avons voté suffisamment de
crédits pour répondre aux besoins de
l'année 2020 la réponse est oui et s'il
y avait une consommation plus rapide que
prévu nous avons le plf dauphin de
gestion le plfr 4-2 fins de gestion pour
éventuellement abondée et faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait aucun problème de
disponibilité de crédit d'ici la fin de
l'année 2021 c'est la moitié du plan de
relance qui sera engagée la moitié du
plan de relance parce que nous aurons
baisser les impôts de production la
moitié du plan de relance parce que nous
aurons dépensé au minimum 10 milliards
d'euros sur l'année 2020 sans compter
les efforts faits en matière de chômage
partiel
la moitié du plan de relance puisque
nous avons inscrit 22 milliards d'euros
de crédits paiement dans le plf pour
2021 qui pourraient être engagés et vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que nous avons
veillé avec bruno le maire a une
parfaite fongibilité des crédits de la
mission relance de manière à ce qu en
cas de besoin sur une ligne nous
puissions redéployer les autres lignes
nous sommes mairie la relance est là il
suffit de la mettre en oeuvre
mais
si monsieur le ministre la parole était
monsieur jean-michel miss merci monsieur
le président la question à laquelle je
souhaite associer mes collègues du
groupe d'amitié france arménie et son
président jacques mallet notion
s'adresse à monsieur francky stehres
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
dimanche les combats ont pris d'ampleur
sur le territoire du haut karabagh 58
morts seraient à ce stade a dénombré et
chacun des progrès des protagonistes a
déclaré la loi martiale
ce matin même les combats se sont
intensifiés touchant directement pour la
première fois le territoire de la
république d'arménie à mort civile
seraient à déplorer dans la ville de
vars des listes
ces événements constituent une nouvelle
étape dans un conflit larvé depuis près
de 30 ans cette région est devenue le
coeur d'un conflit politique les
militaires majeures dans le sud-caucase
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
la représentation nationale est
conscient de la gravité de la situation
nombre de mes collègues se sont
d'ailleurs ému et je sais monsieur le
ministre que vous partagez nos
inquiétudes ou comment ne pas l'être
monsieur le ministre comment ne pas être
inquiet quand les vies de 145 mille
personnes d'un territoire peuplé à 95%
d'arméniens d'un territoire
historiquement arméniens sont
ouvertement pris à partie
menacé par la partie adverse comment ne
pas partager l'inquiétude des six cent
mille français d'origine arménienne
comment ne pas être inquiet lorsque la
raison et la rationalité sont délaissés
au profit des calculs de court terme et
à l'exacerbation du nationalisme
monsieur le ministre
la france copréside le groupe de minsk
celui-ci deux s'étaient réunis
d'ailleurs le 14 septembre soit dix
jours avant l'offensive azerbaïdjanaise
le président de la république l'a
souligné avant-hier lors de ses
entretiens téléphoniques avec le premier
ministre arménien nikol pashinian et le
président azerbaïdjanais ilham aliyev
la priorité absolue est l'arrêt des
hostilités engagé au haut karabagh et
sur le territoire arménien et le retour
nécessaire à un processus de dialogue
monsieur le ministre la question est
donc très simple compte tenu de la
situation actuelle sur le terrain
que peut faire votre pays pour que le
droit des populations du haut karabagh
et de l'arménie à vie
dans la paix et la sécurité attention à
la sauvette à monsieur franck riester
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'europe des affaires étrangères merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
miss vous avez raison il y a des raisons
d'être aujourd'hui inquiet sur la
situation au karabagh la situation fait
qu'aujourd'hui de nombreux civils sont
touchés avec des dizaines de morts
arméniens avec de nombreux blessés et
donc la communauté internationale doit
se mobiliser
d'une façon très énergique le président
de la république le ministre des
affaires étrangères sont mobilisés la
france au sein du groupe de minsk dont
je parlais tout à l'heure et
particulièrement mobilisés des échanges
ont eu lieu comme vous le rappeliez avec
le premier ministre arménien avec le
président de l'azerbaïdjan et le
président de la république nous
souhaitons avec les deux autres
coprésidents du groupe de minsk la
russie les états-unis trouver les voies
et moyens pour un cessez le feu rapide
et bien évidemment trouver une solution
négociée pour sortir par le haut de
cette crise au haut karabagh le groupe
de minsk se mobilisent au sein du
conseil de sécurité les trois
coprésidents interviendront cet après
midi à new york comme je le rappelais
tout à l'heure pour évoquer cette
question et faire part de leur point de
vue sur la situation
les trois coprésidents aussi
interagissent avec les différentes
parties prenantes et la france échange
d'une façon très importante avec ses
partenaires européens et ses partenaires
au sein de l'osce et de l'eau et c'est
l'eau et cee pour trouver une solution
la solution c'est le cessez le feu et la
solution c'est un négociations qui
permet de trouver une sortie crise
diplomatique est derrière une sortie de
crise en s'appuyant sur le droit
international
rien d'autre ne permettra de faire en
sorte que l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
soit en paix demain merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur jean
paul lecoq
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères alors
que chacun attendait une expression du
président de la république sur
l'attentât de vendredi à part
la conférence de presse tenue dimanche
depuis l'elysée sur la situation du
liban avait un très mauvais air de déjà
vu
la dernière fois qu'un président
français a parlé d'un pays dans ces
termes choisis ce peuple s'en souvient
encore c'était la libye l'ingérence dont
fait preuve le président est un acte
insupportable et humiliant envers le
peuple libanais ne serait-il pas assez
mature pour être souverain les pouvoirs
se choisir un gouvernement les députés
communistes vous demande pourquoi
imposer un ultimatum
pourquoi parler si facilement de
trahison quand la situation est aussi
complexe
pourquoi balayer tous les partis
politiques et particulièrement le
hesbollah de votre plan de
reconstruction
nous n'avons aucune sympathie
particulière pour eux mais il
n'appartient ni à nous ni au président
ni à aucun autre français de dire aux
libanais qui ils doivent élire et si
tous les partis politiques sont exclus
du futur gouvernement libanais est ce
que ce seront macro natanyahou et trump
qui le choisiront est ce que ce sont eux
qui vont écrire le programme de réformes
qu'aurions nous dit si un chef d'état
était intervenue en pleine crise des
gilet jaune pour demander la démission
de notre président dans une france
apparaît sans fractures et est dirigé
par un président totalement impopulaire
certains l'ont dit ainsi et il leur a
été répondu
mêlez vous de sécu de ce qui se passe
chez vous le plus grave
comme le dit l'historien hicham
safieddine c'est que cette feuille de
route porté par le fmi et la france
pourrait offrir au pays
un soulagement immédiat est apparent
mais portent à long terme les gemmes les
germes d'un effondrement politique
économique assurée puisque le projet
dead repose sur des privatisations
imposées au profit de ceux justement que
le président accusé d'avoir ruiné le
pays
nos amis libanais n'ont besoin que de
solidarité pas d'ingérence
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un monsieur franck riester ministre
délégué auprès du ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'europe
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés et monsieur le
député lecoq
vous le savez vous qui connaissez bien
les questions internationales la
diplomatie française s'appuie sur un
certain nombre de principes
ces principes c'est d'abord le respect
de la souveraineté l'indépendance des
états c'est la défense des intérêts de
la france et des français
c'est aussi vous le savez une attache
une attention à la complexité de chaque
situation à la complexité de chaque pays
et c'est une diplomatie qui est partout
en plein accord avec ses principes et en
plein accord avec l'université
l'universalité des droits de l'homme en
ce qui concerne le liban et vous le
savez très bien au delà des besoins
humanitaires immédiats et la france
était au rendez vous et un grand nombre
de forces vives et associative française
était au rendez vous il est urgent de
réformer le système politique libanais
et la france est en plein échange est
plein partenariat avec ses partenaires
internationaux est mobilisé pour trouver
une solution pérenne à l'organisation
politique et financière libanaise
personnes connaissant l'histoire de la
france et du liban n'aurait compris que
la france ne soit pas en première ligne
pour permettre aux libanais et au liban
de trouver une solution en la matière
alors le président de la république
dimanche n'a fait que rappeler les
responsabilise les responsabilités
libanaise en la matière ce n'est pas à
la france de prendre les responsabilités
qui doit être les responsabilités des
forces politiques libanaises dans cette
crise est donc ce sont bien sûr les
responsables libanais que repose la
responsabilité à la fois de trouver à la
mi temps de mettre en place un
gouvernement de mission et ensuite de
mener les réformes qui permettront à ce
pays de sortir de la crise économique et
sociale dans laquelle il se trouve
aujourd'hui le président la république
n'a fait que rappeler ses principes
essentiels
merci monsieur des moeurs
monsieur le ministre la parole est un
monsieur michel delpon le président
monsieur le ministre
économie des finances et de la relance
le budget de l'écologie représente le
tiers du plan de relance soit 30
milliards d'euros le double du budget
initial signal fort de la volonté du
gouvernement d'accélérer la transition
environnementale et de réconcilier
écologie économie pour le monde de la
presse une lecture attentive du plf 2021
nous démontre que certaines dispositions
sur l'énergie les risques naturels la
biodiversité des transports son
traditionnel ainsi ce ne sont pas tant
de milliards qui ont été octroyés mais
bien 40,2 milliards d'euros de dépenses
verte favorables à l'environnement
comprenant la lutte contre le
réchauffement la prévention des risques
naturels la gestion de la ressource en
eau l'économie circulaire et la gestion
des déchets la lutte contre les
pollutions et pour finir la protection
de la diversité en tant que président du
groupe d'étude sur l'hydrogène
je salue le travail collégial réalisé
entre les députés le gouvernement et la
filière hydrogène qui a permis
d'attribuer un budget de 7,2 milliards
d'euros
merci ça fait trois ans et à cette
énergie d'ici 2030 dont 2 milliards sur
2021 2022
quel chemin parcouru depuis ma première
question sur l'hydrogène en mai 2018 qui
avait d'ailleurs été suivi d'un premier
plan d'amorçage à 100 millions d'euros
et qui remportait un vif succès en terme
de réponse aux amis lancé par l'ademe
aujourd'hui notre maîtrise technologique
ce budget de passage à richelle inscrits
dans le cas de france relance nous
permet de nous propulser au rang des
leaders européens la création d'un
comité national de l'hydrogène répondre
favorablement à notre demande de
gouvernance pouvez-vous aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre vous apporter des
précisions sur l'organisation
son déploiement ces missions l'assiette
de répartition des budgets et un
calendrier de mise en oeuvre
merci monsieur ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci ce sera madame agnès pannier
renage ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie qui va vous répondre sur le
député merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député del pont
permettez-moi d'abord de saluer le
travail que vous avez fait en tant que
président du groupe d'étude sur
l'hydrogène à l'assemblée nationale
travaille qui a évidemment nourris ce
plan hydrogène ambitieux que bruno le
maire et barbara pompili ont annoncé
début septembre un plan hydrogène
ambitieux car comme vous l'avez
mentionné ces 7 milliards d'euros
d'investissements qui vont permettre à
la france de se positionner parmi les
leaders mondiaux de l'hydrogène et pas
de l'hydrogène grille mais de manière
totalement assumée de l'hydrogène vert
de l'hydrogène décarbonés de celui qui
permettra de réaliser la transition
écologique et énergétique que vous nous
faire nous voulons faire de la france
une des nations leader mondial d'ici
nous voulons faire émerger dès demain
les entreprises qui seront les maillons
indispensables de cette filière
industrielle
nous voulons faire également de
l'hydrogène une des technologies
incontournables pour la décarbonation de
nos activités décarbonation nos
activités industrielles d'une part et
décarbonation de nos mobilité je pense
aux trains l'hydrogène je pense aux
moteurs à l'hydrogène pour les voitures
pour les transports en commun je pense
également qui est un peu un horizon que
j'espère atteignable à l'avion à
hydrogène sur lequel airbus a annoncé
vouloir s'engager récemment pour faire
pour soutenir ses ambitions ses 7
milliards d'euros vont être déployés
très prochainement nous soutenons en
parallèle le lancement d'un grand projet
européen eee pc hui qui sera à l'image
du du projet d'airbus de la
batterie qui nous permettra d'installer
dans les prochaines années des gigas
factory autour de l'hydrogène et de
créer de l'emploi
car il s'agit bien aussi de recoller
localiser de l'emploi et de construire
notre souveraineté technologique
le comité national
l'hydrogène s'installera prochainement
il sera présidé par bruno le maire il
réunira l'ensemble des entreprises de la
filière petites et grandes
ainsi que des filiales à leur service
dans l'auto etc
la parole est à madame caroline
la france ne s'est pas remise du
confinement
derrière les fermetures et les mesures
fortes qui reviennent pour faire face à
une recrudescence du virus idéal
souvenir chaque français se souvient de
ce printemps sans masque sans blouse
sans protection pour des soignants
exténué luttant démunis contre le virus
le président de la république avait
alors prononcé un discours pour avertir
nous sommes en guerre nos soldats de la
santé manquait terriblement d'équipement
hier il n'y avait pas de masque
demain ils seront trop cher a financé
par les professionnels de santé
en effet à compter du 5 octobre les
infirmières libérales ne pourront plus
bénéficier des dotations de l'état pour
ceux masqués dans le même temps les prix
explosent les professionnels de santé
qui font tenir le pays debout depuis
près de six mois se voit infliger un
coup supplémentaire
le prix des gants souvent produit en
dehors du pays ont doublé ces dernières
semaines les professionnels sont
victimes du dogme de la concurrence
libre et non faussée vous promettiez
d'aider le monde de la santé quoi qu'il
en coûte
finalement ce sont les spéculateurs qui
décide des prix et que dire du cadeau
fut au laboratoire alors qu'ici le
parlement avait voté l'obligation de
stocker pendant quatre mois des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeure ce délai pourrait être amenée à
deux mois avoir un seul
c'est cette mesure est contraire à
l'intérêt général le bon sens monsieur
le ministre c'est de se prémunir d'une
seconde vague pas de chercher à
reproduire ce qui n'a déjà pas marcher
pendant la première vague
c'est une lourde différence entre votre
conception votre vision de la santé est
la nôtre vous vous soumettez à la
spéculation et au laboratoire faisant fi
de l'intérêt sanitaire des français
monsieur le ministre
quand allez-vous sérieusement érigé
l'intérêt sanitaire des français en
priorité nationale
merci madame la parole à monsieur
olivier ferrand ministre des solidarités
et de la santé mais la députée fiat je
note pardon hein peut-être qu'ils
relèvent un peu d'un paradoxe puisque
vous vous mettez en avant une mesure que
vous jugez importante qui est l
obligation pour les laboratoires de
stocker des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur sur le territoire
en me reprochant presque de ne pas le
faire alors j'en ai été l'auteur madame
fiat et que nous l'avons adoptée au
parlement une majorité massive et que la
mesure est en train de se mettre en
place
le décret se pare d'une durée maximale
de quatre mois
la loi parler d'une durée maximale de
quatre mois selon les traitements est ce
qu'il s'agit d'une vaccination est ce
qu'il s'agit de médicaments qui peuvent
ne serait-ce que ce que ce qu'on servait
plus de quatre mois évidemment la durée
va varier en fonction de cela mais cette
mesure on pouvait s'enorgueillir de la
regrettée vous et moi madame fiat
c'était une bonne mesure mais je vous
remercie de l'avoir rappelé il ya
d'autres bonnes mesures madame la
députée fiat que vous allez voter
j'espère pareil dans le plfss qui vous
sera présenté puisque vous êtes très
attaché et je le sais en sincérité aux
soignants et à leur quotidien
celles ci ont les mesures du ségur vous
allez voter les 8,2 milliards d'euros de
revalorisation de salaire pour plus d'un
million et demi de soignants la plupart
du temps des femmes j'en suis sûr vous
allez voter les 6 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour l'hôpital et les
ehpad
vous allez j'en suis sûr voter les 13
milliards d'euros de reprise de la dette
des hôpitaux pour pouvoir desserrer
l'emprise qui est sûre les hôpitaux doit
permettre d'investir
vous allez j'en suis sûr voté avec nous
avec la majorité par dont la création de
4000 lits supplémentaires dans les
hôpitaux
vous allez voter j'en suis sûr le
recrutement de 15000 soignants
supplémentaire à l'hôpital
vous allez j'en suis sûr voté également
les mesures qui vont ils venir en aide
aux aides à domicile dans le cas du
plfss et de la loi autonomie à venir
donc vous allez voter des choses que
nous portons et qui sont des choses qui
vont dans le bon sens qui vont dans le
sens de l'intérêt collectif et qui sont
des mesures sans précédent en termes
d'ampleur d'amplitude et d'impact sur
notre système de santé
on peut ne pas être d'accord sur
beaucoup de choses banales fiat ça nous
arrive souvent
je suis sûr que la du tombereau d'accord
merci merci monsieur
madame fille at 10 secondes donc rien
sur les infirmières libérales qui
payeront leur équipement de protection
individuelle
elle vous remercie est passé de 4 mois à
un mois de stocks non je ne suis pas
d'accord
merci la parole que madame sophie mette
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé
olivier véran monsieur le ministre la
semaine dernière vous avez pris la
décision de fermer des salles de sport
dans les zones d'alerté renforcée est
maximale cette décision ne laisse que
peu de place à l'adaptation selon les
situations et les territoires de fait
elles semblent disproportionnés pour de
nombreux acteurs du secteur qui vous le
savez dénonce un manque de concertation
vous savez aussi la sensibilité de cette
question à l'heure où de nombreuses
entreprises et salles de sport se trouve
dans une situation délicate voire
critique pour certaines il faut donc
avancer en faisant preuve d'un peu plus
de démago de pédagogie pour entraîner
les acteurs du secteur qui ont tous joué
le jeu des règles sanitaires et qui ont
adapté leurs locaux ne négligeons pas
non plus le fait que la pratique
sportive est un atout pour la santé
physique et mentale
ceci d'autant plus dans le contexte
anxiogène dans lequel nous nous trouvons
enfin un protocole sanitaire validé par
votre ministère a été rédigée afin
d'assurer une pratique sportive protégé
au sein d'une salle de sport samedi
matin je me suis rendu dans une salle de
sport de ma circonscription et j ai
rencontré plusieurs gérants de salles
à titre d'exemple sur cette
circonscription les clubs de sport
représente 5000 adhérents et ne dénombre
aucun cas de covile 19 répertoriés dans
ces clubs depuis leur réouverture au
mois de juin dernier
la période qui s'ouvre de septembre à
octobre est la période la plus
importante pour eux puisque c'est la
période des adhésions nous devons
craindre dans ce contexte des
résistances de plus en plus forte aux
décisions qui sont légitimement prises
pour faire face à cette situation
égalitaire que nous connaissons c'est
pourquoi il est nécessaire
plus que jamais d'avancer dans la
concertation et dans la co décision pour
que nous puissions aboutir à des
décisions coordonnées et proportionnée
en fonction des territoires
monsieur le ministre comment pouvez-vous
comment pouvons-nous à l'avenir nous
engager sur un processus de codécision
plus large dont les acteurs des services
concernés puissent être aussi parties
peuvent preneur et j'avais l'impression
d'être incompris sol et à monsieur
olivier véran ministre des solidarités
de la santé madame la députée comme je
comprends votre question est le sens de
votre question
sincèrement et je comprends parfaitement
la détresse non seulement des usagers
des salles de sport mais de celles et
ceux qui les tiennent
d'autant qu'ils ont eu un protocole
sanitaire qu'ils ont été fermés pendant
la période de confinement en france
comme partout ailleurs que la
réouverture s'est fait dans des
conditions difficiles avec des mesures
sanitaires très strictes à tâtons et que
là alors que l'activité reprend hélas
nous sommes obligés contraint en tout
cas le gouvernement a fait le choix de
leur demander de fermer dans un certain
nombre de territoires pour une période
de temps je peux vous le garantir madame
la députée que nous souhaitons le plus
court possible
plusieurs éléments de réponses d'abord
pourquoi les salles de sport est-ce qu
est-ce que c pas antinomiques quand on
est ministre de la santé de la compagne
et la fermeture de salles de sport même
temporaire le score est évidemment bon
pour la santé
d'ailleurs l'activité sportive sera
maintenue pour le scolaire et le
périscolaire les gymnases par exemple
pourront rester ouverts dans ces
situations là pourquoi les salles de
sport parce que je le disais tout à
l'heure pour les bars et restaurants
c'est pas de la responsabilité c'est pas
de la faute des personnes qui tiennent
ces salles mais tous les endroits clos
où on ne porte pas de masque où il peut
y avoir de la sueur des sondés endroit
hélas qui sont propices à la diffusion
des rues ce que nous disent les
scientifiques les médecins et ce qui est
fait dans tous les pays du monde qui
font face à une recrudescence de
l'épidémie comme celle à laquelle nous
faisons face dont le plus court possible
et deuxième élément c'est il y aura un
dédommagement et un accompagnement
économique bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie de la relance recevra
l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière
des salles de sport dans les prochains
jours je crois la semaine prochaine en
fin de semaine pour pouvoir
évidemment les accompagner toute la
période nécessaire je vous garantis
qu'il ya des mesures des décisions qu'on
prend pas part par moments qui sont pas
faciles et comprend même d'arâches coeur
c'est le cas pour les bars pour les
restaurants pour les salles de sport
encore une fois
souvenons nous de l'objectif protéger la
santé des français lutter contre la
diffusion du virus éviter d'en arriver
dans les territoires ou satie recule
trop vite à des situations qu'on ne
pourrait plus contrôler parce qu'alors
les conséquences économiques sociales
démocratiques sportive serez sans doute
beaucoup plus importante que celle ci
merci monsieur le ministre je la parole
à madame valérie boyer qui jeudi à zéro
heure nous quittera pour le sénat
j'espère que vous ne regretterez autant
que vous nous regretterons vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président pour battre
élégance effectivement c'est ma dernière
question et monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues je dois vous dire
que je suis très ému ému car
effectivement je quitterais l'hémicycle
prochaine le sénat suite à l'élection de
dimanche
je veux merci je veux de nouveau
remercié les électeurs des bouches du
rhône ma famille politique de leur
confiance en particulier le président de
groupe damien abad et vous dire ma
fierté de ses 13 années passées
allez-vous à l'assemblée nationale et
des combats menés ensemble
je pense à la lutte contre l'extrême
maigreur ou l'obésité aux violences
conjugales à la naissance des ip j'ai
notamment avec le savon de marseille au
respect de la dignité humaine et je dois
vous dire que grâce aux républicains
grâce aux premiers groupes d'opposition
nous avons renforcé la protection des
victimes
comment ne pas penser aujourd'hui à la
pénalisation du négationnisme du
génocide de 1915 voter sur ces bancs et
ceux du sénat
et je veux y associer mon collègue guy
teissier le conflit armé qui renaît
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan doit
mobiliser la france et la communauté
internationale l'azerbaïdjan satellite
de la turquie est entré en guerre contre
les arméniens haut karabagh où les
villes et les populations civiles sont
prises pour cibles ce territoire berceau
de la civilisation arménienne et dont la
population fut de manière ininterrompue
au cours de l'histoire composé d'armes
mia a conquis de haute lutte sa liberté
il y a plus de 20 ans le 12 juillet et
sur plusieurs jours l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise a même attaqué l'arménie
l'azerbaïdjan armée soutenue par la
turquie membre de l'otan
l'arménie est une soeur pour la france
qui doit et la france doit dénoncer ces
attaques
nous avons une responsabilité historique
est universel au regard du génocide de
comment la france est-elle concrètement
mobilisés comment rester neutre lorsque
depuis plusieurs jours erdogan avant ce
que les populations civiles sont
attaqués les femmes et les enfants ont
été tuées à stepanakert capitale du haut
karabagh la neutralité ne saurait être
un blanc seing aux torrents cif turcs et
azéris qui n'ont qu'un seul objectif
l'éradication de la population
arménienne une nouvelle épuration
technique encore un génocide
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole à monsieur franck riester
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
l'europe des affaires étrangères merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée boyer permettez moi
aussi de vous féliciter pour votre
élection au sénat madame la députée je
comprends votre émotion la situation au
karabagh effectivement nous ne pouvons
pas à continuer d'accepter que ce
conflit armé une phase des victimes des
victimes civiles par dizaine
actuellement et des centaines de blessés
le président la république et le
ministre des affaires de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères comme je lé rappeler
tout à l'heure sont totalement mobilisés
le président de la république dès
dimanche a appelé le premier ministre
arménien appelé le président de
l'azerbaïdjan
nous sommes avec nos coprésidents du
groupe de minsk qui nous paraît être la
bonne instruments pour répondre à la
crise
les états unis et la russie parce que
nous savons bien que ce conflit
malheureusement peut avoir des
conséquences qui dépassent l'arménie et
qui dépasse l'azerbaïdjan mais aussi
toute la région et donc ce n'est qu'une
réponse internationale forte qui nous
permettra de sortir par le haut de cette
crise
donc le président de la république
a demandé à toutes ces équipes de faire
en sorte qu'avec les coprésidents ils
sont en contact permanent en lien avec
les parties prenantes pour obtenir un
cessez le feu rapide
nous sommes mobilisés au sein du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu nous sommes
mobilisés au sein de la bce
nous sommes mobilisés pour que cesse ce
conflit là et que nous puissions avoir
une sortie par le haut négocier pour
enfin après tant d'années de conflits
des conflits parfois évidemment mortels
comme malheureusement aujourd'hui nous
puissions avoir une sorte une si une
solution négociée entre les différents
partenaires vous pouvez compter sur la
france pour être totalement mobilisée
comme je le rappelais madame la députée
boyer merci monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions au gouvernement et
terminer la séance est suspendue